offiziell herzlich willkommen in unserem
heute plus live stream studio wo es sich
in den nächsten jahr wir müssen mal
gucken minuten oder stunden um die
ministerpräsidentenwahl in thüringen
drehen wird der zweite anlauf der erste
anlauf am 5 februar der ist ja aus sicht
vieler parteien und vieler menschen
nicht so gelaufen wie er hätte laufen
können oder hätte laufen sollen
ganz kurz zur erinnerung wir hatten eine
landtagswahl im oktober 2009 10 in
thüringen und dort hatten wir folgende
sitzverteilung wie gehen wir hier auf
meinen rechner
da ist die sitzverteilung das ist der
thüringer landtag zurzeit 21 sitze für
die cdu 29 für die linke 8 für die spd
22 für die afd 5 für die grünen und fünf
für die fdp und das heißt dass bodo
ramelow zwar die wahl gewonnen hat mit
29 sitzen aber zusammen mit den
wunschpartnern den grünen und der spd
nicht auf die erforderliche 46 sitze
mehrheit kommt die sehen wir hier weil
der thüringer landtag hat 90 sitze
insgesamt und um da irgendwas
beschließen zu können braucht man halt
46 sitze die rot rot grüne koalition
schafft das nicht ganz den vielen vier
sitze sie kommen zusammen auf 42 und
trotzdem hat sich bodo ramelow am 5
februar dazu entschlossen sich zur wahl
zu stellen so und was dann passiert ist
wissen die meisten wahrscheinlich noch
es gab einen ersten wahlgang es gab
einen zweiten weigern die afg hat einen
eigenen kandidaten aufgestellt aber
nicht beirren hocke gehen wir zurück
vielleicht in die andere kamera ihren
landesvorsitzenden und fraktionschef
sondern einen bis dato völlig
unbekannten nämlich christoph
kindervater der bürgermeister in der
gemeinde sunthausen
den haben sie auch zwei wahlgänge lang
gewählt und im dritten wahlgang dann auf
einmal nicht mehr weil im dritten
wahlgang der läuft ein bisschen anders
als die ersten beiden da reicht eine
einfache mehrheit hat die fdp einen
eigenen kandidaten aufgestellt nämlich
thomas kemmerich
die fdp habe gerade gesehen dass ein
relativ kleine fraktion im thüringer
landtag
und die haben trotzdem mal gedacht okay
wir versuchen das mal und die afg hat
zugeschlagen und hat dann gemeinsam mit
stimmen von der cdu muss man sagen
thomas kemmerich zumindest präsidenten
gewählt das war ein ziemlicher aufschrei
in der ganzen republik hatte in der
folge dann die konsequenz dass annegret
kramp karrenbauer angekündigt hat nicht
mehr cdu-parteivorsitzende sein zu
wollen und auch nicht kanzlerkandidatin
sie ist es noch aber es wird ja gerade
fleißig gesucht ja und thomas kemmerich
hat die wahl tatsächlich angenommen das
ist ihnen von vielen parteien
vorgeworfen worden das ist am ende auch
in der fdp nicht gut angekommen
christian lindner hat das ganze auch
nicht gutgeheißen aber thomas kemmerich
ist bis jetzt geschäftsführender
ministerpräsident von thüringen
er hat gesagt er trete zurück nach zwei
tagen war obwohl doch zu groß aber er
ist natürlich im amt geblieben weil
irgendeiner sollte ministerpräsident in
thüringen seien trotzdem ist die
regierung im land eigentlich sollte hier
wochen gelernt
es läuft zwar alles seinen gang aber im
grunde gibt es keine minister es gibt
niemanden der beschlüsse fällt der
landtag kann ich tragen und das wird
sich eventuell heute ändern so wir sind
schon das signal und wir glaube wir
sollten mal drauf schalten das ist dicke
keller die präsidentin des landtags für
thüringen von der linken sowie die
vertreterinnen und vertreter der medien
sowie die zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
die über andere kanäle heute hier bei
uns im haus zu gast sein werden
sehr geehrte damen und herren bevor wir
in die heutige tages irgendein steigen
ist es mir ein wichtiges anliegen einige
worte zu den schrecklichen ereignissen
in unserem nachbarland hessen vor genau
zwei wochen zu sagen hanau selbst
trauert heute unter dem motto die opfer
waren keine fremden am 19 februar dieses
jahres wurden zehn menschen durch eine
ähnliche gewalttat mitten aus dem leben
gerissen
diese rechtsextremistische anschlag hat
uns alle bis ins mark erschüttert
die schrecklichen taten erfüllen uns
alle mit tief empfundener trauer und
besonders im 75 jahr der befreiung vom
nationalsozialismus mit großer scham die
mord serie der nsu ja mordfall lübke der
anschlag von halle und nun hanau diese
blutspur des hasses die der
rechtsextremismus durch unser land zieht
ist nicht weniger als eine schande für
unsere gesellschaft
wir müssen dieses problem klar benennen
und entschlossen bekämpfen
denn rechtsextremismus und fremdenhass
sind die größten bedrohungen mit der
sich unsere demokratie konfrontiert
sieht wir demokratinnen und demokraten
sind in der verantwortung
zusammenzustehen und in jedem moment
deutlich zu machen rechtsextremismus und
fremdenhass haben in unserer
gesellschaft keinen platz
ich bitte sie sich nun für einen moment
der stille und des gedenkens zu erheben
vielen dank
sehr geehrte damen und herren
abgeordnete als schriftführerin hat
neben mir platz genommen frau
abgeordnete maurer die rede liste führt
herr abgeordneter aus für die heutige
sitzung hat sich entschuldigt frau
abgeordnete dr
werk noch bevor wir zur feststellung der
tagesordnung kommen möchte ich die
gelegenheit nutzen dem am montag aus dem
amt geschiedenen vorsitzenden der
fraktion der cdu herrn abgeordneten mike
mohring für die geleistete arbeit zu
danken und dem neuen
fraktionsvorsitzenden herrn abgeordneten
professor dr
mario voigt zu seiner wahl zu
gratulieren und alles gute zu wünschen
sehr geehrte damen und herren
abgeordnete der ältestenrat hat in
seiner fünften sitzung am 25
februar 2020 gemäß § 17 absatz 4 satz 1
der geschäftsordnung zahlreichen
weiteren medienvertreterinnen und
medienvertreter eine dauer
arbeitsgenehmigung für die siebente
wahlperiode für bild und tonaufnahmen im
plenarsaal erteilt auf die ihre nennung
ich mit ihrem einverständnis hier an
dieser stelle verzichten möchte die
einzel akkreditierungen für die wahl des
ministerpräsidenten am 5 februar 2020
gelten für die heutige wahl fort sehr
geehrte damen und herren einige hinweise
zur tagesordnung
der ältestenrat hat gemäß § 29 absatz 2
satz 1 der geschäftsordnung bis auf
weiteres beschlossen dass grundsätzlich
diejenigen tagesordnungspunkte der
anstehenden plenarsitzungen für die die
geschäftsordnung die verhandlungen in
einfacher redezeit vorsieht in gekürzter
redezeit und grundsätzlich diejenigen
tagesordnungspunkte für die die
geschäftsordnung die verhandlung in
langer redezeit vorsieht in einfacher
redezeit zu verhandeln
die fraktionen haben in ihrer
plenarsitzung woche die möglichkeit bis
dienstag um 14 uhr jeweils einen
tagesordnungspunkt zu benennen der ein
einfacher bzw in langer redezeit
verhandelt werden soll die fraktion der
afg hat den tagesordnungspunkt 8 dafür
benannt die fraktionen die linke der cdu
der spd bündnis 90 die grünen und der
fdp haben keinen tagesordnungspunkt
benannt weiterhin sind die fraktionen im
ältestenrat überein gekommen den
tagesordnungspunkt 1 und gegebenenfalls
die tagesordnungspunkte zwei bis vier
heute aufzurufen nach tagesordnungspunkt
2 wird die sitzung gegebenenfalls zur
vorbereitung der tagesordnungspunkte 3
und 4 unterbrochen
die tagesordnungspunkte 5 a und b
werden am freitag als erster punkte und
der tagesordnungspunkt 6 wird in diesen
plenarsitzungen auf jeden fall
aufgerufen
die fraktionen sind überein gekommen die
wahlen zu den tagesordnungspunkten 21
bis 34 am donnerstag nach der
fragestunde aufzurufen
zu tagesordnungspunkt 1 wurde ein
weiterer wahlvorschlag verteilt diese
wurde von der fraktion der afg
eingebracht und liegt ihnen in der
drucksache 7 strich 418 vor die
beschlussempfehlungen zu den
tagesordnungspunkten 5 a und b haben die
drucksachen nummern 7 strich 385 und
sieben strich 386 der wahlvorschlag der
fraktion der afg zu tagesordnungspunkt
21 hat die drucksachen nummer 7 strich
394 der tagesordnungspunkt 22 wird von
der tagesordnung abgesetzt da die
fraktion der afg keinen wahlvorschlag
eingereicht hat die wahlvorschläge der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen und der
fdp gesorgt 23 haben die drucksachen
nummern 7 strich 376 und sieben strich
396 die wahlvorschläge der fraktionen
bündnis 90 die grünen und der fdp zu
tagesordnungspunkt 24 haben die
drucksachen nummern 7 strich 377 und
sieben strich 397 die wahlvorschläge der
fraktion darf die und die linke zu
tagesordnungspunkt 25 haben die
drucksachen nummern 7 strich 395 und
sieben strich 429 die wahlvorschläge der
fraktion da fdp und die linke zu
tagesordnungspunkt 26 haben die
drucksache nummern 7 strich 298 und
sieben strich 428 die wahl vorschlagen
der fragt vorschläge der fraktionen der
afg und die linke zu tagesordnungspunkt
27 haben die drucksachen nummern 7
strich 399 und sieben strich 400
23 die wahlvorschläge der fraktion darf
die und die linke zu tagesordnungspunkt
28 haben die drucksachen nummern 7
strich 400 und 7 strich 431 die
wahlvorschläge der fraktion darf die und
die linke zu tagesordnungspunkt 29 haben
die drucksachen nummern 7 strich 400 und
1 und 7 strich 426 die wahlvorschläge
der fraktion der afd der cdu und die
linke zu tagesordnungspunkt 30 haben die
drucksachen nummern 7 strich 400 und 27
strich 419 und sieben strich 432
der wahlvorschlag der fraktion die linke
zu tagesordnungspunkt 32 hat die
drucksachen nummer 7 strich 400 und 30
die wahlvorschläge der fraktion der afd
der cdu und die linke zu
tagesordnungspunkt 33 haben die
drucksache nummern 7 strich 403 420 424
die wahlvorschlag vorschläge der
fraktionen der fdp der cdu und die linke
so normal herzlich willkommen hier im
studio allen die jetzt erst
eingeschaltet haben hier in unseren live
stream aus nahm heute plus live studio
wir haben jetzt noch mal kurz runter
geschaltet weil die tagesordnungspunkt
verlesung ist jetzt nicht super
interessant einfach noch mal zusammen
zur zusammenfassung für alle die es
vielleicht ein bisschen vergessen haben
oder nicht nur so richtig wissen was
passiert ist will ich es nochmal kurz
erläutern also wir hatten am 5 februar
eine wahl zum ministerpräsidenten des
freistaats thüringen das sollte
eigentlich bodo ramelow werden zumindest
war dass sein plan und der plan seiner
gewünschten rot rot grünen koalition die
bis dahin ja schon gemeinsam das sagen
zumindest für die thüringer ganz gute
arbeit geleistet haben aber wenn wir mal
kurz auf die sitzverteilung gucken die
die wahl in thüringen ergeben hat dann
sehen wir haben auch meinen monitor
gehen hier
es braucht zusammen 46 sitze im landtag
weil der landtag hat 90 sitze und
zusammen haben linke spd und grüne
einfach nicht die erforderliche mehrheit
gehabt was dann folgte wissen die
meisten wahrscheinlich thomas kemmerich
der fdp-kandidat im dritten wahlgang
wurde dann ministerpräsident von
thüringen mit den stimmen der afd und
der cdu das gab einen großen aufschrei
hatte im endeffekt zur folge dass
annegret kramp karrenbauer nicht mehr
cdu parteivorsitzender sein will und er
ist ein neuer vorsitzender und eine
kanzlerkandidatur ein kanzler kandidat
gesucht wird und was jetzt heute
passieren soll ist quasi der zweite
anlauf einen ministerpräsidenten für
thüringen zu finden so und da gab es im
vorfeld viele gerüchte ist wurde viel
versucht von seiten der linken und der
gewünschten rot rot grünen koalition die
erforderlichen noch vier stimmen die sie
brauchen damit bodo ramelow
wiedergewählt werden kann irgendwie zu
organisieren aber das große problem ist
vor allem die haltung der cdu dort
gewesen für die linke und die spd und
die grünen
denn die cdu haben die cdu hat einen so
genannten unvereinbarkeit beschluss das
heißt cdu hat auf einem parteitag
beschlossen dass sie weder mit der
linken noch mit der afg gemeinsame sache
macht sie irgendwie unterstützt dann gab
es auch große diskussionen ob die cdu
dann nicht vielleicht mit ungleichem
maßen ist ob die linke und die afg
tatsächlich so miteinander zu
vergleichen sind die cdu hat sich
dagegen gewehrt hat gesagt mit der afg
machen wir nicht zusammen aus ganz
einfachen gründen das
demokratieverständnis ist und mit der
linken können wir nicht zusammen gehen
weil die linke einfach ganz viel von
unserem politischen verständnis nicht
teilt von unsere ideologie nicht teilt
so das problem ist jetzt rot rot grün
grün in thüringen wenn es denn so kommen
sollte fehlen vier stimmen die cdu hat
in einer probeabstimmung die cdu
thüringen verlauten lassen dass von
ihnen niemand
bodo ramelow wählen wird auch das war im
vorfeld irgendwie schon diskutiert
worden ob das nicht vielleicht eine
möglichkeit wäre dass wir so eine
elegante lösung gewesen
die cdu thüringen kann als fraktion
sagen wir wählen ihn nicht aber es ist
natürlich für jeden abgeordneten die
sache mit dem mit dem freien willen er
ist nicht gebunden oder sie ist nicht
gebunden
das heißt es kann durchaus sein könnte
passieren dass wurde so zwischen den
zeilen quasi laut oder deutlich dass
vielleicht doch jemand für bodo ramelow
stimmt und das ist im ersten wahlgang
dann tatsächlich für ihn reichen würde
jetzt aber hat die cdu quasi verlauten
lassen nein wir haben in der
probeabstimmung
macht niemand möchte für modulrahmen nur
stimmen kann man aber auch wieder sagen
gut wer möchte sich vor der eigenen
fraktionen da vielleicht tatsächlich
outen eventuell passiert das doch so und
was da noch passiert ist dass die afg
überraschend für einige für andere nicht
so doch ihren landeschef und
fraktionsvorsitzenden bernd höcker
aufgestellt hat der doch durchaus
umstritten ist durch viele äußerungen
die im nationalen nationalistischen
rahmen könnte man sagen gefallen
es wird ihm rassismus vorgeworfen er
darf nach einem gerichtsurteil als
faschist bezeichnet werden
und er hatte im ersten wahlgang am 5
februar gesagt er tritt nicht an weil
sein öffentliches bild von den medien so
zerstört worden sei jetzt wird er sich
aber doch zur wahl stellen wobei offen
ist in welchen drei gängen tatsächlich
stellt vielleicht mal zum procedere
das kennt ja vielleicht auch nicht jeder
das wird so ablaufen dass es im ersten
und im zweiten wahlgang eine absolute
mehrheit braucht sprich diese 46 stimmen
die wir hier gerade gesehen haben von
den 90 im thüringer landtag
und wenn dann niemand auf die 46 stimmen
kommt dann gibt es einen dritten
wahlgang und dort reicht die einfache
mehrheit sprich wer die meisten stimmen
hat das könnte tatsächlich so was sein
wie ein krieg nur fünf und andere kriegt
2 dann ist der mit den fünften
ministerpräsident von thüringen
das heißt spätestens im dritten wahlgang
wird es spannend und da ist die frage
wie sich die afg verhalten wird es gab
gleich nach der wahl am 15 februar einen
mehr oder weniger süffisanten kommentar
von herrn bauland von der afg
bundesebene
der sagt ja dann werden wir halt einfach
die nächste mal module und dann muss er
die wahl ja eigentlich auch ablehnen
weil mitbestimmen kann man sich ja
anscheinend in deutschland nicht wählen
lassen
ob das tatsächlich heute passieren dass
hier und wird passieren könnte ist
völlig offen die afg hat sich dazu nicht
festlegen wollen hat sich quasi da
nichts mehr zu geäußert und dann hat
gesagt wir gucken einfach mal hier und
heute hat auch gesagt ich schaue jetzt
einfach mal von walkern zu weigern wie
ich mich verhalte und das ganze wird
jetzt so ablaufen die wahlzettel werden
verteilt werden die wahl als erster
tagesordnungspunkt
quasi losgeht dann wird gewählt dann
wird ausgezählt dann wird geguckt wie es
aussieht wenn es im ersten wahlgang
nicht reicht gibt es einen zweiten
wahlgang
das heißt dann muss das ganze prozedere
von vorne losgehen wahlzettel parteien
abstimmen auszählen
dann kommt der zweite wahlgang damit
wieder geguckt ist die absolute mehrheit
da und wenn das dann nicht der fall sein
sollte gibt es im dritten wahlgang und
dann geht es da von vorne los so wir
sehen hier im thüringer landtag wird
gerade noch nicht so richtig viel
gemacht es wird gesessen und gewartet
dann nutzen wir die zeit doch mal um mit
dem politikwissenschaftler karl rudolf
korte zu sprechen der ist mir jetzt
zugeschaltet hallo herr korte sie hören
mich ja ich kann sie gut an hallo
wunderbar eine leichte verzögerung haben
wir drin aber das macht nichts
herr korte um es mal ganz grob gefragt
womit rechnen sie denn heute
es gibt ja eine erwartung sicherheit
gegenüber dem nicht erwarten das haben
wir in thüringen erlebt mit
überraschungen umzugehen das lernt man
wenn man sich mit erfurt näher
auseinander setzt das lässt sich nicht
vorhersagen da gibt es so viel
überraschungs möglichkeiten heute von
dem mathematischen möglichkeiten bis zur
stilistischen dann lass uns doch mal die
verschiedenen möglichkeiten durch gehen
die wir da haben also wir haben einmal
gehört die einfachste möglichkeit wäre
ja bodo ramelow wird im ersten wahlgang
gewählt kriegt woher auch immer vier
stimmen dann wäre der drops quasi
gelutscht was gibt es denn noch
naja die vier stimmen ist erstmal dann
wäre er gewählt wir können aber auch
davon ausgehen dass vielleicht die
gesamte fdp fraktion auch ramelow
mitwählen wird wie es der
bundesvorsitzende der gaul hat auch
empfohlen hatte dann wäre ja die
variante dass er zwar insgesamt
ausreichend stimmen hätte um gewählt zu
sein
herr ramelow aber würde dann natürlich
die wahl nicht annehmen weil das ja
kontaminierte stimmen sind mit denen er
auf keinen fall ministerpräsident werden
fangen wir mit wahlgang nummer eins
wieder an das wäre eine variante die
völlig abenteuerlich klingt aber der afc
ist alles zuzutrauen und der die ard
versucht ja das vertrauen in die
institutionen wir zu zerstören und damit
auch wichtige teile der demokratie weil
sie wie ein zocker praktisch mit den
institutionen die bewährt sind bislang
umgegangen ist das heißt wenn es jetzt
ganz unglücklich läuft könnte das ganze
sich immer wieder wiederholen
der rahmen so stellt sich zur wahl er
wird mit den stimmen der afg gewählt
nimmt die wahl nicht an und dann fängt
wieder von vorne an und spart wann
sollte man denn da die notbremse ziehen
und sagen so geht es nicht
naja ist die frage wer am ende in den
weiteren weil gingen dann noch
kandidiert das wissen wir nicht bisher
ist es so dass nicht die fdp spontan
wieder sagen wird dass sie einen
kandidaten bereits die cdu hat das auch
gesagt insofern könnte man hoffen auf
einen geläuterten prozess im dritten und
letzten wahlgang bei denen dann die
relative einfache mehrheit ausreichen
würde
und dort ist klar davon auszugehen dass
bei der konstellation wenn niemand
anderes antritt außer herr wirke die
einfache mehrheit eindeutig dann bei
herrn ramelow wäre all das ist aber eine
logik die normalerweise greift aber die
ich selbst für diesen tag heute nicht zu
100 prozent so sehen würde
das war dass wir müssen uns ein bisschen
drauf verlassen dass um das relativ
kompakt zu halten
sowohl die cdu als auch andere parteien
die jetzt nicht unbedingt mit der mit
der linken einverstanden sind aber auch
nicht mit der afg erwischt werden wollen
sich möglichst ruhig verhalten und
einfach gar nicht abstimmen
ja sich enthalten das wäre eine saubere
variante für die ersten wahlgänge alle
male und auch bei dem letzten würde es
letztlich ausreichen um eine klare
mehrheit als einfache mehrheit für
rot-rot-grün hinzubekommen sozusagen die
füße stillhalten aber das setzt sehr
viel vertrauen auch unter den
verschiedenen abgeordneten voraus und
wir erinnern uns das sehr viel dieses
vertrauens ja zerstört worden ist in den
letzten wochen so fern ist es voller
risiko ob sich die abgeordnete die
natürlich nur ihren eigenen gewissen
verpflichtet sind an solche absprachen
oder auch vertrauens bündnisse halten
die doch sehr brüchig sind so wir haben
ja eine frage auf twitter von schrotten
ator der oder sie möchte wissen wird es
denn heute definitiv ein finales
wahlergebnis geben
nein das kann man so nicht sagen
es besteht immer noch die möglichkeit
zum beispiel das im dritten wahlgang
kein kandidat antritt
auch das schließt sich nicht aus so dass
dann die wahl nicht vollzogen würde
sondern vertagt wird die logische
konsequenz wäre dann ein antrag
einzubringen zur auflösung des landtags
der braucht nicht so viele stimmen
er braucht als antrag nicht viele aber
um beschlussfähig zu sein für die
auflösung braucht man doch wieder zwei
drittel mehrheiten also 60 abgeordnete
im landtag es könnte sein nach diesem
spektakulären zweiten versuch wenn der
misslingt doch eindruck auf 60
abgeordnete lastet zu einer zügigen
auflösung des landtags zu kommen kann
mir mal kurz heute nicht zwingend mit
der präsidentin mit
ministerpräsidentenwahl abstieg da kann
man noch mal kurz auf die sitzverteilung
schauen herr korte
um das mal vielleicht ganz anschaulich
zu machen wir haben ja hier sehen wir
auf einem monitor schauen den können sie
jetzt gerade nicht sehen aber sie werden
vielleicht die sitzverteilung
mittlerweile auswendig im schlaf herbei
beten können bei der cdu 21 bei der
linken 29 bei der spd 8 bei der afg 22
sitze bei der grünen 5 und bei der fdp
findet das heißt für eine zweidrittel
abstimmung die nötig wäre bräuchten wir
wir haben hier die gesagt 90 sitze
bräuchten 60 abgeordnete haben sie
gerade gesagt wir mal zusammen zählen
die linke hätten interesse neu zu wählen
die spd und die grünen vielleicht auf
das auch das sind zusammen 42 sitze
jetzt muss man überlegen die fdp nicht
so wirklich weil wir jetzt einen
umfragen gezeigt haben die durch dieses
wahl debakel doch ziemlich
haben die cdu bräuchte man auch oder die
afd mindestens und hätten haben cdu und
fdp daran den landtag jetzt wirklich
aufzulösen
jetzt kommt über an wie es kommunikativ
dargestellt wird
im moment hat man eher den eindruck dass
es ein nachteil wäre für die union wenn
es jetzt zu neuwahlen käme wenn die
union aber kommunikativ sagt sie haben
jetzt alles versucht um doch nicht der
fc auf den leim zu gehen sie haben alles
versucht um auch vertragstreu gegenüber
der bundes partei zu bleiben und sehen
keinen ausweg mehr
dann könnte vielleicht auch milde walten
dass sie am ende doch einige von ihnen
zumindest nicht bekehren
doch für die auflösung des landtags zu
votieren
ansonsten haben sie sicher bis april
also viele ein jahr praktisch zeit
genommen um dann sich neu zu sortieren
ich halte es nicht für ausgeschlossen
wenn man am ende es kommunikativ so
positiv wenden kann dass man vielleicht
ein leitungs prozess der cdu daraus
ableiten kann sie werden nicht
realisieren bei der wahl sie werden
nicht zusätzliche stimmen bekommen das
glaube ich nicht aber sie werden
vielleicht auch nicht katastrophal
abstürze hängt also davon ab wie sie mit
dem heutigen tag dann umgehen würden
falls es zu diesem szenario kommen
könnte
das kann ja auch in den nächsten wochen
noch passieren mit einem
ministerpräsidenten ramelow der dann
doch sich nicht fähig zeigt aus der
minderheit heraus für bestimmte themen
wichtig vor allem das haus der haushalt
für das kommende jahr
doch eine mehrheit hinzubekommen so dass
er doch vorher aufgeben musste und
vorzeitig dann doch vor einem jahr eine
landtagsauflösung notwendig wäre noch
mal zu den fans kurzer korte wir würden
gern nach die thüringen schalten eine
fdp abgeordnete der fdp abgeordnete ist
offenbar krank
insofern haben wir heute nun nur vier
abgeordnete fdp im plenum das stimmt das
wurde gerade gesagt von birgit keller
vielen dank herr korte bis hierhin wir
haben noch weitere gelegenheit je
nachdem wie lange das heute dauert
miteinander darüber zu reden über die
möglichen konstellationen
jetzt möchten wir erstmal wieder in den
thüringer landtag schalten denn dort
läuft jetzt der erste wahlgang das heißt
die wahlzettel
verteilt wurden und es wird abgestimmt
henri christophe
sehr geehrte damen und herren
abgeordnete konnte jeder jede stimme
abgeben
ich sehe keinen widerspruch dazu dann
stelle ich fest dass alle abgeordneten
ihre stimme abgeben konnten
ich schließe die wahlhandlung und bitte
um auszählung der stimmen bitte
das macht
diese sperren
bringen sie mir auch nicht
so die abteilung und die auszählung
nicht die erzählung die auswertung läuft
wir haben es gerade gesehen alle
abgeordneten haben ihre stimmzettel
abgegeben sind namentlich aufgerufen
worden jetzt wird dort tatsächlich
händisch gezählt wer für wegen gestimmt
hat und natürlich sind wir sehr gespannt
ob quasi jetzt im ersten wahlgang gleich
alles schon vorbei ist oder ob wir hier
in die erste verlängerung gehen müssen
wir haben uns da gerade gehört von
parteienforscher karl-rudolf korte mit
dem wir auch noch nachher nochmal
sprechen möchten das heißt wenn ihr
fragen habt könnt ihr sie gerne in die
kommentare posten wir versuchen sie
damit aufzunehmen wir sprechen noch
gleich unserer korrespondentin melanie
hart die ist vor ort
die wir das ganze auch für uns
einschätzen und erläutern also bitte
fragen aus es gibt quasi keine dummen
fragen was das angeht der ganze vorgang
ist relativ komplex und nicht
unkompliziert von daher muss man sehen
dass ich nicht für auch eine ganz
rudimentäre frage kämen sage ich jetzt
mal wir versuchen die wird nicht alle
hier zu erläutern damit hier keiner raus
geht und sagt ich habe nicht verstanden
worum es geht also es wird jetzt
ausgezählt
ramelow braucht damit er zum
ministerpräsidenten gewählt wird 46
stimmen sicher hat er 42
und jetzt ist die frage ob aus einer
anderen fraktion vier andere stimmen
dazu kommen sowohl die zweitgrößte
fraktion die afg wird natürlich nicht
für den stimmen die haben wir in höckel
aufrufen wahrscheinlich wenn sie nicht
für ihn stimmen das war auch da ein
fragezeichen dahinter die cdu hat gesagt
sie wird nicht für ihn votieren es kann
aber auch sein dass eine geheime
abstimmung
das da trotzdem jemand ausschert und
vielleicht wird ein ramelow stimmt um
das ganze schauspiel möglichst kurz zu
halten
aber wie gesagt wir haben uns gerade von
herrn korte gehört die unvorhergesehen
dieses unvorhersehbare ist das einzige
was gerade vorhersehbar ist wir schauen
jetzt mal da wird jetzt was
aufgeschrieben das heißt es könnte sein
dass wir schon ein ergebnis haben 90
stimmen kann man ja relativ fix
ausziehen und dort wird jetzt es sieht
ein bisschen aus als ob sie zusammen
rechnen
und mal schauen da gibt es die
verschiedenen stapel wer hat die viel
bekommen
das ergebnis wird wenngleich zu birgit
keller getragen
der präsidentin des landtags in
thüringen die das dann verkündet und
dann werden wir sehen ob es einen
zweiten wahlgang geben muss das ist
gerade völlig offen
hier wurde auch gerade gefragt was
passiert eigentlich wenn herr ramelow
mit der stimme der afg gewählt wird und
dann die wahl ablehnen muss muss er
natürlich nicht er könnte sich auch
annehmen hat aber auch schon gesagt dass
wir nicht tun und das wird auch von
allen wahrscheinlich auch so erwartet
dass er sich nicht mit dem stimmen die
fdp lässt wobei man muss erstmal
auszählen werden tatsächlich für wegen
gestimmt hat von der afg wissen wieviele
sitze sie hat dann kann man gucken wie
viele fehlen da quasi also wie viele
stimmen hat die ecke bekommen denn man
kann davon ausgehen dass außer der afg
niemand für bestimmen wird so und jetzt
gehen tatsächlich die damen und herren
dahin wir schalten wir wieder zurück und
guckt muss das ergebnis an
sehr geehrte damen und herren
abgeordnete ich vorlese das ergebnis der
wahl abgegebene stimmzettel 85 gültige
stimmzettel 85 enthaltungen 21 auf den
wahlvorschlag der fraktion die linke der
spd und bündnis 90/die grünen drucksache
7 strich 340 entfielen 42 ja stimmen auf
die in wahlvorschlag der afd drucksache
7 strich 418 entfielen 22 stimmen damit
stelle ich fest dass keiner der
wahlvorschläge die gemäß artikel 70
absatz 3 satz 1 der verfassung des
freistaates thüringen in verbindung mit
§ 47 satz 1 der geschäftsordnung die
erforderliche stimmenzahl von mindestens
46 stimmen erreicht hat herr
abgeordneter blechschmidt bitte danke
frau präsidentin mit blick auf den
nächsten wahlgang bauantrag meiner
fraktion eine auszeit von 30 minuten
damit gehen wir in einer auszeit von 30
minuten wir treffen uns hier wieder 15
uhr 5
das war quasi der erste wahlgang und
weniger ausmacht die ergebnisse angucken
ich habe für mich geschrieben 85 stimmen
wurden abgegeben
das heißt das heißt die fdp hat sich
wenn wir einfach mal aufs ergebnis
gucken hier auf die sitzverteilung
wahrscheinlich komplett enthalten das
müssen wir jetzt einfach mal annehmen
weil das fünf stimmen von den grünen
fehlen ist eher unwahrscheinlich
wir haben 21 enthaltungen
das könnte die das könnte die cdu
gewesen sein und 42 stimmen für den
ramelow das sind die linken die grünen
und die spd um 22 stimmen für ein hocke
das ist geschlossen die afd
also herr korte ist mir zugeschaltet
wieder wir können also konstatieren jede
partei hat quasi erst mal für ihren
kandidaten abgestimmt
die cdu hat sich komplett enthalten und
die fdp anscheinend auch also erst mal
alles gut
das sieht nach einem sehr
disziplinierten wahlgang aus jeder hat
sich an die vereinbarung ganz
offensichtlich gehalten und jetzt wird
in der pause weiter taktiert was daraus
für konsequenzen für die zweiten
wahlgang erwachsen können aber die
überraschung das was weise die afd den
eigenen kandidaten nach absprache keine
stimme geht es offenbar im ersten
wahlgang schon mal nicht eingetroffen
aber wir haben im ersten wahlgang eben
auch keine sogenannten kontaminierten
stimmen für herrn ramelow der ihnen über
diese berühmte 640 stimmen würde gehoben
haben insofern muss es einen zweiten
wahlgang geben
so jetzt können wir gerade die frage ob
die fdp den raum verlassen hat ehrlich
gesagt konnte ich das nicht beobachten
es wurden ja auch fünf stimmen abgegeben
das heißt sie haben abgestimmt
sie sind nein sie sind im raum geblieben
im landtag haben sich aber an der wahl
nicht beteiligt das kann man das mandat
ist so frei dass man alles damit machen
kann
aber es widerspricht natürlich eines der
zentralsten grundsätze eines
abgeordneten gibt nichts wichtigeres als
das wahlrecht als abgeordneter für einen
ministerpräsidenten wahrzunehmen sich
überhaupt nicht zu beteiligen
widerspricht
nicht dem charakter des abgeordneten da
sagen insofern ist das zwar kein bruch
der verfassung aber es sagt sehr viel
aus über das selbstverständnis der fdp
abgeordnete im thüringischen landtag so
herr korte vielen dank erstmal für diese
einschätzungen wir haben jetzt 30
minuten quasi zeit die ihre gemeinsame
überbrücken können ein bisschen
überlegen was man da jetzt daraus machen
kann und meine kollegin melanie haack
ist im thüringer landtag
ich sehe sie noch nicht nur 210 sehr
schöne bilder aus dem thüringer landtag
sie wird aber gleich mit sicherheit
kommen da er sie hallo melanie du hast
mich super ja wir haben jetzt hier
gerade ja ich höre und ich erzähle
einfach mal los im moment ist ja eine
pause anberaumt von den linken für 30
minuten
man will sich nach diesem wahlergebnis
jetzt erst mal zurückziehen und wir
sehen hier hinter uns der plenarsaal
die meisten sind jetzt erstmal raus
gegangen und man musste fdp sagen die
sind sitzengeblieben vier von fünf sind
angewiesen anwesend der fdp und sie sind
nicht aufgestanden und zur urne gegangen
soviel zur fdp und ja mit blick auf die
linke ist es eigentlich erwartbar das
ergebnis hier im ersten wahlgang das
bodo ramelow eben seine eigene mehrheit
mit 42 stimmen hat und björn höcke der
afg chef 4 in thüringen 22 stimmen hat
jetzt ist die große frage wird es weiter
so gehen ja und dann gehen wir bis zum
dritten wahlgang oder wird sich jetzt
noch eine fraktion anders entscheiden
wenn die kannst du mal erklären warum
oder hast du eine ahnung warum die linke
sich das quasi zurückgezogen hat man
könnte doch jetzt auch einfach
weitergehen weil das
abstimmungsverhalten hat der
parteienforscher herr korte gerade als
diszipliniert beschrieben also im grunde
hat jeder das getan was in der situation
wie man sie gerade hat für seine
fraktion
mehr oder weniger als gesichtswahrende
ist bei der fdp wird wahrscheinlich auch
wieder kritik kommt aber trotzdem es ist
nichts völlig unerwartetes passiert ja
die frage ist jetzt was wird die afd
wir haben gestern noch mit der fdp
gesprochen und es hieß man stehe klar
hinter höcke im ersten wahlgang
was wir danach tun wir hatten sprich im
zweiten oder dritten wahlgang das
entscheiden wir dann aktuell am tag und
jetzt heißt es natürlich wieder
überlegen was passiert sollte die afd
im zweifel blöcke zurückziehen oder ihm
nicht die volle stimme zu geben wo
würden die afg stimmen dann hingehen
würde die im zweifel bodo ramelow
bekommen und dann hätte er auf einmal 46
stimmen die absolute mehrheit die er ja
auch noch im zweiten wahlgang braucht
und vielleicht wir wissen es nicht
hinter verschlossenen türen redet man
jetzt spricht man mit der cdu ob die cdu
tatsächlich bei der enthaltung bleibt
das hatte sich ja heute am vormittag
klar angekündigt in allen drei
wahlgängen sich zu enthalten und die cdu
hatte auch eine probeabstimmung gemacht
und alle hatten sich für eine enthaltung
ausgesprochen also ich denke dass man
jetzt darüber redet welche planspiele da
jetzt denkbar sind
jetzt ist hier ist es ja so gewesen das
war so ungefähr vor zehn tagen der fall
dass man sich eigentlich ja schon
geeinigt hatte also es gab ja quasi
einen deal zwischen der rot rot grünen
koalition und der cdu thüringen die
haben gesagt okay wir müssen irgendwie
gucken wie wir hier rauskommen aus der
situation
die cdu hat kein großes interesse haben
wir auch gerade von den korte gehört
jetzt sofort neu wählen zu lassen weil
durch diese zwei debakel hat man
natürlich ein bisschen an reputation
verloren und dann sollte es ja nächstes
jahr weitergehen also erstmal quasi eine
geduldete minderheitsregierung was ist
aus den plan eigentlich geworden
ja also der up plan steht grundsätzlich
da hat man sich ja auf den oder
bahnvertrag nennt man es ja nicht dass
es ein protokoll das im übrigen auch
heute vormittag unterzeichnet wurde
darin hat man festgelegt was inhaltlich
passieren soll da hat die cdu sich
eingebracht es gibt mehr geld für die
kommunen es geht um das thema schulen
viele themen die sie einbringen konnten
auf die hat man sich geeinigt und vor
allem den haushalt in diesem jahr durch
zu bringen und die cdu hat es geschafft
damit die neuwahlen
von diesem jahr wegzuschieben bis zum
april im nächsten jahr darauf konnte man
sich einigen aber wie wir gehört haben
hat man nie über die vier stimmen
gesprochen weil die cdu ja in der klemme
steckt ja zum einen dieser
bundesbeschluss der cdu der halt eben
ein paktieren mit den linken nicht
erlaubt und zum anderen eben diese
schwierigen thüringer verhältnisse hier
aber es gab offenbar nie die garantie
der cdu dass man bodo ramelow diese vier
stimmen gibt was aber schon gesagt ich
würde es stehen ja in thüringen ist so
einiges paradox was sie in den letzten
monaten und wochen passiert ist
das muss man ganz klar sagen aber die
cdu sagt eigentlich wenn wir irgendwie
durchhalten bis zum dritten wahlgang mit
der enthaltung dann wäre es ja so dass
bodo ramelow mit 42 stimmen von
rot-rot-grün mehr stimmen hätte als
brücke von der afd
ich kannte ja auch passieren dass ein
dritter wagen dann auf einmal die afg
denselben buch macht wie vor knapp vier
wochen und einfach komplett für ramelow
stimmt und dann haben wir quasi eine
situation die wir auch schon mal hatten
und dann ist die frage was passiert dann
wir theoretisch hätten wir die situation
der unterschied ist aber bei der wahl
kammerichs von der fdp war er ja auf
stimmen der fdp angewiesen sonst hätte
er nicht die mehrheit erzielen können im
dritten wahlgang und das wäre bodo
ramelow in diesem fall ja nicht weil er
allein mit rot-rot-grün ja schon die
einfache mehrheit hat wenn er die du
musst erst ein bisschen schauen für uns
mal hinter den kulissen gucken was da
passiert bin gespannt welche infos
zugleich vielleicht heranziehen kannst
was da tatsächlich geredet wird vielen
dank erstmal das hier für deine
einschätzungen und infos
und alle die jetzt gerade quasi erst
zugeschaltet haben weil so richtig
spannend wird es jetzt gerade erst der
erste wahlgang im landtag in thüringen
ist durch es wurden 85 stimmen abgegeben
das heißt die fdp hat sich komplett
enthalten hat auch meine kolleginnen an
die hna gerade gesagt ist etwa sitzen
geblieben und gesagt wir sind zwar da
wir gehen nicht raus das wurde ja auch
mal diskutiert dann gab es auch viel
viel kritik dass die fdp den raum
verlassen würde
die sind nicht rausgegangen sind
geblieben habe aber nicht abgestimmt das
heißt es gab 85 stimmen die tatsächlich
ausgewertet wurden alle waren gültig 21
stimmen haben sich enthalten und das
wird die komplette cdu fraktion gewesen
sein weil die haben genau 21 stimmen das
heißt sie haben das getan was sie
angekündigt haben sie wählen weder den
kandidaten der fdp noch der linken weil
sie sagen sie können das nicht
und herr ramelow ist mit seiner rot rot
grünen mehrheit die er nicht hat eben
nicht dort gelandet wo er landen müsste
nämlich bei 46 stimmen da fehlen immer
noch 44 stimmen damit er quasi zum
ministerpräsidenten gewählt werden wird
das heißt sie gehen den zweiten wahlgang
was dann passiert ist dass die linke
gesagt hat wir brauchen es 30 minuten
mal pause das dürfen sie sie dürfen
quasi eine vertagung beantragen
und im hintergrund werden jetzt
wahrscheinlich gespräche laufen um zu
gucken wie man vielleicht ein ramelow im
zweiten wahlgang als ministerpräsidenten
gewählt bekommt herr korte
wir haben mal schauen ist er da herr
karl rudolf korte hier ist wieder für
mich da wunderbar so wir müssen jetzt
ein bisschen schauen dass wir die zeit
überbrücken das heißt wenn ihr fragen
habt könnt ihr sie sehr gerne stellen
wir versuchen sie alle zu beantworten da
zum beispiel eine frage die auch
berechtigt ist im setup gefragt darf
eigentlich thomas kemmerich spricht
derjenige der bis jetzt gerade
ministerpräsident noch geschäftsführend
ist darf der auch wählen
ja darf auch wählen hat ein wahlrecht
weil er auch ein mandat hat jeder
mandatsträger hat die gleichen rechte
und pflichten es nicht besonders
herausgehoben er hat nicht weniger
möglichkeiten insofern ist das heute ein
tag an dem er wie jeder abgeordnete auch
hätte ab
dem können aber es im raum gewesen hat
sich aber der abstimmung ganz
offensichtlich hinzu hier fragt pascal
becker auf periscope hat ramelow einen
dritten wahlgang eigentlich
ausgeschlossen er hätte da was gehört
ramelow hat ist vor zwei tagen immer auf
den ersten wahlgang gesetzt war
zuversichtlich dass er den ersten
wahlgang ins zentrum auch für seine
ministerpräsidenten schafft rückt er war
zu dem zeitpunkt noch nicht informiert
darüber dass heute eben der kandidat der
fdp sein wird als das bekannt wurde hat
er jetzt seinen kurs geändert und will
die cdu nicht weiter unter druck setzen
auf die afg nicht denn das ist ja die
taktik der afg dass sie die cdu
vorführen möchte dass sie wortbrüchig
wird dass sich fraktion geschlossen
nicht bleibt sondern doch am ende
ramelow und damit den linken
ministerpräsident unterstützt da hat er
also ramelow hat versucht die cdu zu
entlasten
und das ist beim ersten wahlgang ja ganz
offensichtlich aufgegangen insofern
setzt er jetzt auf die ganz einfache
relative mehrheit im dritten wahlgang so
ich glaube wir müssen mal oder wir
könnten mal einfach nochmal ganz hinten
anfangen herr korte wir haben jetzt ein
bisschen zeit bis das zum zweiten
wahlgang geht die situation wie wir sie
vor vier wochen vorgefunden haben das
mit den stimmen der fdp
ministerpräsident gewählt wurde mit dem
niemand gerechnet hat das ist ja in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik relativ
einmalig was vielleicht noch mal zur
einordnung für alle die sich bis jetzt
aber noch fragen was eigentlich jetzt
das große problem damit ist wo sehen sie
da diesen tabubruch von dem immer
geredet wird
es gab zwei
[Musik]
besonderheiten bei der zurückliegenden
wahl die eine besteht darin dass man es
als einen bürgerlichen sündenfall
bezeichnen kann dass demokratische
parteien der mitte es geradezu gewagt
haben auch die afg mit zu wählen eine
partei die in thüringen eben durch die
flügel vorherrschaft von der lücke
mittlerweile vom verfassungsschutz der
flügel beobachtet wird also eine
rechtskonservative und farbigen auch in
vielen teilen rechtsextremen partei ist
völkische gesinnung ins zentrum gerückt
hat mit ideologie auch beschrieben in
einzelnen buch beiträgen wirke das
gemacht insofern das ist der erste
bürgerliche sündenfall eine
rechtsextreme partei mit zudem der
zweite sündenfall im hinblick auf die
demokratie besteht darin einen
kandidaten aufzustellen
die man überhaupt keine stimme gibt also
null stimmen wie die afg es gemacht hat
dem eigenen kandidaten der ein
parteiloser bürgermeister war aus
thüringen und mit dem man praktisch
gezockt hat gespielt hat um das system
und die das institutionengefüge das amt
des ministerpräsident ist ja eine
institution vorzuführen beides zusammen
führt zu einer besonderheit
jetzt haben wir gerade diskussion sie
hat gesagt bürgerliche partei
das ist ein begriff den könnten sie mir
als parteienforscher vielleicht mal
genauer erklären weil die afg sagt ja
immer wir sind eine bürgerliche partei
und sie versuchen von diesem label
rechtspopulismus vielleicht sogar
rechtsradikal in manchen gebieten
loszukommen wie würden sie an der
bürgerlichen partei definieren
die ard hat sicherlich bürgerliche
wähler aber die akteure der partei sind
eher bürger darstellende akteure
bürgerlich heißt auch nicht nur dem
grundgesetz verpflichtet zu sein sondern
nicht auszugrenzen ein integrationsamt
wahrzunehmen
inhaltlich heftig zu streiten aber doch
in der wahrnehmung der aufgaben zu
versuchen alle bürger einzuschließen
einzugrenzen zu integrieren und das
macht die ard nicht dass weniger
demokratische und das auf keinen fall
bürgerliche ist daran eben eine politik
zu betreiben indem man andere ausgrenzt
und das bürgerliche ist eben eine
moderne form von autonomie das ist das
wie ein notstands orientierter kaufmanns
geist es ist moralischer ernst das sind
attribute auch ein bestimmter stil in
der politik
die abgrenzung läuft vor allen dingen in
der richtung dass man politik betreibt
um die rein mehrheitsfähig zu werden und
nicht andere auszugrenzen das ist der
große unterschied und das ist auch die
markierungs linie zwischen bürgerlicher
und nicht bürgerlicher politik aber man
könnte doch da auch sagen also wenn man
dann bürgerlich denkt hat man die man
wie sie gerade sagten so jemanden das
moralisch integer ist dann vielleicht
ein kaufmann oder ist ein angestellter
also ist weder jetzt irgendwie sozial
schlechter gestellt als andere
das ist ja auch immer so dieses bild was
man früher hatte von rechtsradikalen die
mit bomberjacken und springerstiefeln
durch marodierend durch die gegend zogen
aber das ist ja genau klientel was die
hsg auch wählt das sind ja für die ich
jetzt sagen ganz normale bürger zum teil
genau deswegen habe ich ja auch
differenziert zwischen den wählern die
zurück gewinnbar sind auch für eine
bürgerliche mitte und den politiker der
afc und den verantwortlichen der ft die
ich eher als bürger darstellen
bezeichnen möchte vor allen dingen in
thüringen weil sie eben eine ideologie
betreiben mit ihrer politik ausgrenzend
zu agieren und zwar nicht bei
generell bei themen sondern vor allen
dingen ausgrenzen gegenüber bestimmten
bevölkerungsgruppen und das heißt
bürgerlich ist etwas was mit
bürgerlichen habitus und bürgerlichen
impulsen mit bürgerlicher politik nichts
zu tun das heißt bürgerlich hat für sie
nichts damit zu tun was für ein anzug
man trägt was für ein auto man fährt
welchen beruf man hat sondern eher was
für eine geisteshaltung man gegenüber
anderen menschen hat die vielleicht
anders denken die einen anderen
hintergrund haben eine wird an der
biographie haben anderes aussehen haben
und insofern ist es eine frage aus
habitus stil aber eben auch aus einer
programmatik heraus die
grundgesetzkonform die würde des
menschen ins zentrum rückt und nicht die
würde von bestimmten bevölkerungskreisen
ausgrenzt oder die würde von bestimmten
bevölkerungsteilen zum etat miert
geradezu und/oder ist ein abschluss sei
gibt dort und die trifft genau
vielleicht für alle die jetzt gerade
zuschauen eingeschaltet haben uns
gefunden haben wir sprechen mit karl
rudolf korte parteienforscher über die
vorgänge in thüringen die ja doch sehr
außergewöhnlich sind wir machen gerade
den die zweiten großen wahlgang für für
den ministerpräsidenten in thüringen wir
sind da einen im zweiten wahlgang quasi
kurz davor die linke hat gesagt sie
möchte eine auszeit haben ist das
eigentlich normal herr korte dass man so
zwischen den wahlgängen sagt so wir
machen wir eben kurz timeout wie beim
football und wir müssen uns mal kurz
beraten und neue strategie auf unser
flipchart malen also bei den normalen
wahlen die wir kennen mit mehrheiten die
absehbar sind selbst wenn sie mit einer
stimme mehrheit eine mehrheitskoalition
geschmiedet haben ist das absolut
ungewöhnlich aber hier tritt ja eine
minderheitsregierung an das ist nicht
ungewöhnlich
ich kenne das auch mit vielen stunden
manchmal pausen dazwischen auch von der
wahl des der bundespräsidentin die ja
auch in drei wahlgängen gewählt werden
können in dem manchmal bis zu neun
stunden es gedauert hat bis am ende
die drei wahlgänge abgeschlossen ist
also nicht ungewöhnlich
das ist immer dann und nicht
ungewöhnlich wenn eine mehrheit nicht
vorab absehbar ist und das ist hier ja
ganz klar der fall weil es eine erste
regierungsbildung ist in thüringen die
auf einer minderheit aufbauen möchte und
insofern durchaus ein modell wählt was
in vielen landesteilen schon der fall
war 27 mal haben wir
minderheitsregierung in der
bundesrepublik seit 1949 gab nicht
ungewöhnlich aber ungewöhnlich war hier
dass man vorab eine
koalitionsvereinbarung rot rot grün
getroffen hat auch das traf nicht auf
große resonanz bei den anderen parteien
das wirkt es schon ein wenig arrogant im
vorfeld eine vereinbarung dieser art zu
treffen er konnte wir wollten wenn ich
jetzt in den landtag zurück schalten
aber ich habe hier eine entgegnung für
sie oft periscope ein user namens
demokratie netz schreibt korte macht aus
seiner abneigung gegen die afg kein hehl
als seriöser kommentator ungeeignet was
entgegnen sie na ja es geht darum wie
man politik die in den landtagen gemacht
wird einordnet und hier geht es darum
wie kann in einer demokratie man mit
vielfalt umgehen das ist auch die idee
einer repräsentativen demokratie die den
stadtstaat von athena verlassen hat und
für viele
ein modell entwickelt hat um sich
einzubringen und mit zu entscheiden und
mitzubestimmen und wer nicht diese
vielfalt als solches ins zentrum rückt
sondern aus der vielfalt aussteigen
möchte der geht mit dem demokratie
gehalt dieser der verfassung nicht nur
kritisch um sondern er missbraucht sie
geradezu insofern kann man durchaus
sagen ist ja nicht nur ein dass der
verfassungsschutz diese partei
beobachtet sondern man kann auch sagen
sie tragen nicht dazu bei den demokratie
gehalt dieser republik zu fördern
sondern sie spielen mit jedem und
insofern muss man benennen was auch
sachlage ist und daraus seine eigenen
schlussfolgerungen ziehen dann konnte
vielen dank erstmal jetzt für ihre
einschätzungen und für ihre kommentare
zu dieser doch sehr spannenden wahl wir
werden später wieder mit ihnen sprechen
wir warten quasi jetzt darauf dass es
für thüringer landtag weitergeht sie
haben noch neun minuten die abgeordneten
um 15 uhr 5 hat die landtagspräsidentin
birgit keller quasi dazu aufgerufen
wieder zusammenzukommen dann geht es in
den zweiten wahlgang für alle die jetzt
gerade erst zu schalten werde ich noch
mal kurz zusammenfassen quasi was bisher
geschah die erinnern uns am 15 februar
gab es die erste wahl zum
ministerpräsidenten in thüringen geplant
war von der linken der spd und der
grünen dass es wieder bodo ramelow
werden soll
der hatte bis dahin das land eigentlich
relativ geräuschlos kann man sagen
geführt wie der thüringer 70 prozent in
umfragen haben es gesagt waren zufrieden
mit seiner amtsführung mit seiner
amtszeit und das problem war jetzt aber
dass bei der wahl 2009 10 im oktober rot
rot grün keine mehrheit mehr hatte im
landtag hin fehlen bis heute vier
stimmen natürlich weil es gab noch keine
neuwahl um überhaupt ja beschlussfähig
zu sein das heißt sie müssen mit anderen
parteien versuchen auf einen konsens zu
kommen damit sie überhaupt im landtag
arbeiten können aber schon der erste war
sie die erste amtshandlung nämlich die
wahl des ministerpräsidenten ist total
daneben gegangen weil nicht bodo ramelow
wurde gewählt sondern thomas kemmerich
von der fdp der sich im letzten dritten
wahlgang hat aufstellen lassen und dann
mit den stimmen von cdu und fdp zum
gewählt wurde der ist bis heute im amt
geschäftsführend zwar hat gesagt er wird
zurücktreten
aber er hat das amt quasi immer noch
inne es gibt derzeit aber keine minister
in thüringen die regierung versucht so
gut zu arbeiten oder die ministerien
versuchen so gut zu arbeiten wie es geht
aber so richtig was passieren kann in
thüringen seit vier wochen nichts mehr
heute soll jetzt das zweite mal versucht
werden ein ministerpräsident zu wählen
weil thomas cannon recht eben
zurückgetreten ist und da gab es im
ersten wahlgang grad das ergebnis des
gab 85 stimmen die abgegeben wurden von
90 21 enthaltungen das heißt dass wir
die cdu gewesen sein die hat komplett
gesagt wir enthalten uns die fdp es
einfach gar nicht zur wahl gegangen so
sieht es zumindest aus weil das wären
genau diese fünf stimmen die vielen 92
und im endeffekt gab es sie auch beim
ersten wahlgang vor vier wochen 42
stimmen für bodo ramelow von der linken
das wird die komplette rot-rot-grüne
mehrheit oder den minderheit muss man ja
sachen im landtag gewesen sein und 22
stimmen für die afg für den fdp
kandidaten gehen hätte auch das wird
seine eigene fraktion im landtag gewesen
sein so jetzt warten wir darauf was als
nächstes passiert ich frage mal kurz in
der regie des die melanie vielleicht
wieder da das mit der noch mal sprechen
können
ok also wir warten jetzt mal ihr könnt
euch vielleicht mal kurz entspannen euch
einen kaffee holen und kurz auf die
toilette gehen oder was zu essen
bitte seid in fünf minuten wieder da wir
machen quasi fünf minuten kaffeepause
weil dann geht es in den zweiten
wahlgang stream nicht ausschalten die
hat doch jetzt die gelegenheit fragen zu
stellen die wir mitnehmen können oder
den stream zu teilen das würde uns auch
freuen dann wird viele leute zugucken
können weil um 15.05 wird es noch mal
spannend und dann geht es in die zweite
runde im thüringer landtag so lange
machen wir hier mal kurz das signal aus
erfurt
[Musik]
sehr geehrte damen und herren
abgeordnete gemäss artikel 70 absatz 3
satz 2 der verfassung des freistaats
thüringen und § 47 satz 2 der
geschäftsordnung findet ein neuer
wahlgang statt wenn im ersten wahlgang
niemand die stimmen der mehrheit der
mitglieder des landtags erhalten hat ich
frage die beiden vorschläge aus dem
ersten wahlgang werden die aufrecht
erhalten ebenfalls aufrechterhalten dann
ist also vorgeschlagen für diesen
zweiten wahlgang erneut herr
abgeordneter bodo ramelow und herr
abgeordneter blöcke gibt es weitere
bewerber
das kann ich nicht erkennen dann haben
wir auch hier im zweiten wahlgang
folgenden stimmzettel auf dem
stimmzettel sind entweder für einen der
beiden kandidaten die möglichkeit mit ja
zu votieren oder sich zu enthalten das
sind die möglichkeiten ich bitte die
wahlhelferinnen und wahlhelfer herrn
abgeordneten schütze herrn abgeordneten
gottweis und frau abgeordnete dr kliesch
erneut nach vorn
damit darf ich die wahlhandlung eröffnen
und ich bitte die schriftführerin
beziehungsweise schriftführer die namen
der abgeordneten zu verlesen bitteschön
adams dirk rené baum franziska beyer
patrick bergdoktor berg na gute spieler
sasa blech mit andré
braga torben andreas kotter jens von
thorsten
dittos steffen egal
cord oder ende volker
kati frosch soll kurz zu erläuterungen
wir sehen dass hier die abgeordneten
werden namentlich aufgerufen müssen dann
hier einmal durch den landtag laufen bis
hier zu dieser stelle bekommen dann
einen wahlzettel hier kommt die nächste
abgeordnete kann man es sehen die erhält
jetzt ihren wahlzettel geht hier in die
wahlurne das kennen wir von der
bundestagswahl da wird geheim abgestimmt
wenn dann die wahl entweder frei wird da
gibt's das gerade ein bisschen stau das
heißt einen kurz das kreuzchen machen
dann wird hier wahlkabine sorry in die
wahlkabine geht es und dann wird hier in
die wahlurne eingeworfen
hier werden sich noch mal kurz noch mal
kurz begrüßt und so schnell ging das
wenn wir einfach über die abgeordnete
verfolgen
das hat jetzt ungefähr 30 sekunden
gedauert
das heißt so ein foul kann geht relativ
fix werden alle einmal durch sind das
heißt alle einmal namentlich aufgerufen
wurden wird die ohne wieder genommen
umgedreht das kommen fünf abgeordnete
zählen das ganze durch und laufen damit
zu birgit keller mit dem ergebnis das
kann jetzt ungefähr noch
ich vermute mal fünf bis zehn minuten
dauern bis wir durch sind mit dem
wahlgang bis ausgezählt wurde
das heißt wir haben das noch ein
bisschen zeit das ganze ist trotzdem
ziemlich spannend weil das dann doch in
der geschichte unseres landes relativ
einmalig das was hier passiert ist
wir können mal schauen ob es fragen gibt
die wir noch nicht beantwortet haben
pascal fragt müssen jetzt alle wählen
weil namentlich aufgerufen wird nein es
müssen nicht alle namentlich also nicht
alle sehen haben wir gerade gesehen
es gab 85 stimmzettel die nicht
abgegeben wurden also 5 und bestimmt
nicht umgekehrt es gab fünf stimmzettel
nicht abgegeben wurden 90 sitze gibt es
im thüringer parlament 85 wurden im
ersten wagen abgegeben
das heißt fünf haben einfach nicht
mitgemacht und das war tatsächlich die
fraktionen der fdp die ist einfach
sitzen geblieben
hier wurden macht pfiffen gefragt habe
ich noch nicht gehört und es geht voll
antifa fahnen vor den fenstern des
parlamentes
da habe ich gerade auch noch nichts
gesehen da habt ihr bessere adleraugen
als ich gehabt kann dass sie irgend
jemand von euch bestätigen habt ihr
antifa fahnen gesehen vor den christian
okay also kollege christian sagt mehrere
leute auf unterschiedlichen plattformen
fragen danach wir haben sie jetzt
tatsächlich nicht beobachtet aber dass
verschiedene augenzeugen nicht kann sie
die dabei waren können wir davon
ausgehen das da vor dem thüringer
landtag gerade etwas passiert dass dort
quasi demonstriert wird das wird
vermutlich auch die pfiffe wir können
aber unsere kollegin melanie haack
gleich noch mal fragen die das ganze für
uns beobachtet und die das auch
einschätzen wird die hat auch gerade in
der 15 uhr heute sendung einmal kurz
geschaltet die kann natürlich nicht die
ganze zeit reden weil die muss gucken
dass jeder informationen zusammen
bekommt ich bin sehr gespannt was sie
uns gleich sagen wird so wir gucken mal
zurück schalten wir dir deine landtag
und schau mal wie weit sie gerade sind
lukas gute
dr lockt ihn gut und maier georg
malsch markus
marx dorothea
maurer katja
meißner beate
mitteldorf katja
mohring mike
müller stefan
montag robert martin
mühlmann ringo
müller anja
müller olaf
ralf
ramelow bruder
reinhard daniel
rothe beinlich astrid
so der zweite wahlgang läuft es wird
weiterhin werden die abgeordneten
aufgerufen und wir haben ja gerade mit
euch besprochen dass es anscheinend vor
dem landtag in thüringen
wir wissen was los ist es wurden antifa
fahnen gesichtet und tatsächlich vielen
dank wir haben gerade von tinkerbell
sway einen screenshot bekommt finde ich
großartig hier ist guckt mal auf meinem
monitor ich machte nummer größer da das
ist der screenshot sogar was für ein
service eingekreist und das sieht ist
ein bisschen verpixelt und ist in
überbelegt sind aber dass sie
tatsächlich nach anti verfahren aus das
ist natürlich geschickt sich da
hinzustellen weil das hier ist das pult
der landtagspräsidentin die sitzt in der
mitte begeht keller hier stehen die
redner also hier ist gerade ja viel
action das heißt diese einstellung gibt
es die ganze zeit immer wieder und dort
haben sich wohl aktivisten aufgestellt
um zu demonstrieren es gab auch pfiffe
zwischendurch wurde gehört ich habe sie
persönlich nicht gehört aber einige
andere user vielen dank klinker bay das
zu uns diesen screenshot geschickt hast
wir nicht großartig so wir gucken mal
wie es da weitergeht weiterhin kommen
abgeordnete werden aufgerufen kriegen
ihren wahlzettel gehen in die wahlkabine
machen ihr kreuzchen und werfen das
ganze dann ein
wir sind aber relativ weit
fortgeschritten ich habe soeben schotten
den namen ramelow gehört das heißt wir
sind im alphabet fasten durch und dann
entweder ausgezählt und dann schauen wir
mal wie es im zweiten wahlgang aussieht
wobei mich persönlich ist ehrlich gesagt
überraschen würde wenn das jetzt anders
aussehe als im ersten
das heißt werden dass jetzt tatsächlich
eine entscheidung geben würde aber wir
wissen es nicht es gab eine 30 minütige
pause zwischen den beiden wahlgängen wo
eventuell die linke versucht hat doch
noch den einen oder anderen abgeordneten
aus der cdu zu überzeugen für bodo
ramelow zustimmen kurz zur erinnerung es
gibt einen sogenannten
unvereinbarkeitsbestimmungen und mit afd
gehen wir nicht zusammen unter keinen
umständen und deswegen hat die cdu
thüringen gesagt wir werden uns bei
dieser wahl enthalten wir wollen gar
nicht abstimmen obwohl es im vorhinein
auch schon so paar gerüchte gab
vielleicht hat der ein oder andere
abgeordnete doch noch aus und sorgt
dafür
ob sich hier zu einem schnellen ende
kommt beim ersten wahlgang 21
enthaltungen gab es passt genau zur
fraktion der cdu hatte das wohl nicht
geklappt aber die fdp hat sich komplett
zurückgezogen hat noch nicht mal ihre
stimmzettel abgegeben denn dort fehlten
beim ersten wahlgang jetzt auch fünf
stimmen das passt genau zur fraktion der
fdp und die sind doch tatsächlich sitzen
geblieben
dh wir sind jetzt gespannt was im
zweiten wahlgang passiert ist sowie
schalten mal zurück da gibt es einen
kleinen stau aber ich glaub den letzten
abgeordneten sind jetzt dabei ihre
stimme abzugeben
sehr geehrte damen und herren konnten
alle abgeordneten ihre stimme abgeben
ich sehe dazu keinen widerspruch damit
stelle ich fest dass alle abgeordneten
ihre stimme abgeben konnten ich schließe
die wahlhandlung und bitte um auszählung
der stimmen
läuft's alle abgeordneten haben ihre
stimme abgegeben und jetzt wird einmal
durchgezählt
das dauert tatsächlich nicht so lange
man sieht hier schon einzelne stapel für
einzelne kandidaten und vier
enthaltungen
da wird vielleicht sich hin und her
geschoben und hier wird tatsächlich
händisch nachgezählt
das heißt wir können damit rechnen dass
ich ungefähr 23 minuten wir das ergebnis
kennen
ich guck mal kurz in die kommentare
ob hier noch fragen kann tatsächlich gab
gerade die frage von pascal der volt
ganz genau wissen wie werden die
abgeordneten aufgerufen
die werden nicht zufällig aufgerufen
sondern alphabetisch nach nachnamen das
heißt der nachname kommt zuerst und am
ende kommt das ende des alphabets sowie
oft ausgezählt zweimal dreimal das kann
ich dir tatsächlich nicht sagen pascal
aber du kannst hier beobachten wir
können ja sehen es gibt mehrere leute
die zählen
das alles ist absolut transparent und
quasi öffentlich wir können hier zu
gucken wie die stimmzettel auf einzelne
stapel landen und dann wird gleich
wieder zusammen gerechnet so auch sehr
schön hier gesehen dieses kleine das
kleine schweinchen mit dem wasser wo man
das papier besser voneinander trennen
kann
es sind die details erzählen so ich bin
gespannt wie viele stimmen fehlten im
ersten wahlgang fragt ingo voigt es
fehlten bodo ramelow vier stimmen für
die erforderliche mehrheit
er hat 42 stimmen bekommen ich kann man
das erstes ersten durchgang bekannt
geben also wir hatten 90 abgeordnete
insgesamt eine art mit der fdp hat sich
krankgemeldet
abgegeben wurden 85 stimmen das heißt
fünf stimmen wurden gar nicht erst
abgegeben
das war geschlossen wahrscheinlich die
fdp-fraktion 21 also die ganze cdu
stimmen haben sich enthalten dass wir
die ganze cdu fraktion gewesen sein und
rot-rot-grün hat wahrscheinlich
geschlossen für bodo ramelow gestimmt
und empfehlen nach wie vor vier stimmen
das heißt wir haben im endeffekt so ein
flashback 25 februar wo ist im grunde
genauso aussah
erster wahlgang funktionierte nichts
weiter war funktionierte nicht und
dritter die überraschung gegeben so hier
ostdeutsch 1661 ostdeutsches der user 50
neuwahlen und bin ich mal also können
wir gespannt sein
weil tatsächlich das große problem bei
der ganzen geschichte ist ja selbst wenn
bodo ramelow jetzt gewählt werden würde
und jetzt wird hier zum
fortgeschrittenen würde ihnen immer noch
im parlament eine mehrheit fehlen so wir
gehen wieder drauf und sind gespannt
sehr geehrte damen und herren der zweite
wahlgang hat folgendes ergebnis ergeben
abgegebene stimmzettel 85 ungültige
stimmen keine gültige stimmte der 85
enthaltungen 21 anwesenden abgeordnete
89 auf den wahlvorschlag der fraktion
die linke der spd und bündnis 90 die
grünen entfielen 42 stimmen auf den
wahlvorschlag der fraktion der afg
drucksache 7 418 entfielen 22 stimmen
damit stelle ich fest dass keiner der
beiden wahlvorschläge die gemäß artikel
70 absatz 3 satz 2 der verfassung des
freistaates thüringen und § 47 satz 2
der geschäftsordnung erforderliche
stimmenzahl von mindestens 46 stimmen
erreicht haben damit herr abgeordneter
prager bitte herzlich ein persönlich
beantragt unterbrechung der sitzung für
den dritten wahlgang nach 41 6 dann ist
die unterbrechung für 30 minuten
angezeigt dann unterbrechen
für 30 minuten und setzen fort um 15 uhr
danke
so das ergebnis des ersten wahlgangs ist
das ergebnis des zweiten wahlgangs das
heißt wie geschichte hat sich komplett
wiederholt 85 stimmen wurden abgegeben
von 90 abgeordneten 89 sind da weil eine
hat sich krankgemeldet von der fdp
das heißt die fdp hat wieder nicht
mitgemacht es gab 21 enthaltungen das
heißt die cdu hat sich wieder komplett
enthalten und herrn ramelow fehlten
wieder vier stimmen um das amt des
ministerpräsidenten in dazu haben wir in
hard hitter 22 stimmen von seiner
fraktion bekommen
das heißt wir warten jetzt wieder weil
die linke hat wieder 30 minuten pause
beantragt das ist um 15 55 und meine
kollegin melanie haack ist im thüringer
landtag hat das ganze gerade beobachtet
so das war absehbar oder doch ja ja es
war absehbar
grundsätzlich ist es die afd die jetzt
die pause eingefordert hat von 30
minuten so dann das hätte natürlich die
große es war die fdp die version und die
frage ist jetzt ja genau
damit korrigiert und damit haben wir
jetzt eine halbe stunde pause und die
frage ist natürlich was wird die afg
jetzt im dritten wahlgang tun der
unterschied zu den beiden anderen
wahlgängen ist ja dass jetzt keiner mehr
die absolute mehrheit braucht sondern
die einfache mehrheit zählt also der der
mehr stimmen auf sich vereinen kann hat
dann die wahl gewonnen
die frage ist wird die afg jetzt ihren
kandidaten zurückziehen was macht sie
mit ihren stimmen wird sie dann am ende
die stimmen wo du ramelow geben um zu
sagen tja unseren kandidaten wolltet ihr
nicht das ist ja die große frage die
sich jetzt hier alle erst mal stellen
wir haben ja gerade schon mal 30 minuten
pause gehabt zwischen dem ersten und im
zweiten wahlgang
du bist da mal rumgelaufen hassen es in
moisling gespielt hast du irgendwas
erfahren was die linke dort vielleicht
versucht hat zu erreichen
nein also weil am ende ist das ergebnis
ja auch das gleiche die vermutung war
vorher ob man doch noch mal mit der cdu
spricht die hat aber auch noch einmal
ganz klar gemacht wir bleiben in allen
wahlgängen bei unserer enthaltung
ich sag mal so im zweiten wahlgang
konnte bodo ramelow jetzt dahingehend
erstmal aufatmen dass er nicht mit
stimmen der afd doch gewählt wurde
das ist ein szenario das haben hier alle
durchgespielt die stimmen mehrten sich
auch dass es drei wahlgänge werden wo du
ramelow war das auch klar dass es so
kommen kann und er hat ja dann heute
morgen auch gesagt ich trete für drei
wahlgänge an
bis dahin hat die linke ja mantraartig
immer klar gemacht wir wollen ihnen
sicher im ersten wahlgang haben also ja
wird setzt man eben auf die einfache
mehrheit im dritten wahlgang wie gesagt
die frage ist nur woher die stimmen
kommen es ist davon auszugehen dass die
cdu sich wieder enthalten wird und die
fdp ist ja jetzt auch im zweiten
wahlgang wieder einfach sitzen geblieben
ist nicht an die urne gegangen und man
muss sagen der stimmzettel auf dem
stimmzettel stehen die namen bodo
ramelow bion röcke und enthaltung also
die fdp hätte sich auch enthalten können
aber sie hat es vorgezogen
auch im zweiten wahlgang sitzen zu
bleiben was ist das für ein signal dass
man nichts wirklich enthalte mich
sondern ich gehe gar nicht erst zur wahl
naja zumindest waren sie optisch
anwesend zur wahl
sie haben den saal nicht verlassen ja
sie wollen damit klarmachen dass sie
keinen kandidaten wählen und auch keinen
eigenen kandidaten sozusagen aufstellen
und damit wäre ja auch klar das ist das
interessante eigentlich an dieser wahl
das jetzt eigentlich das im grunde es
ist zwar eine geheime wahl
aber man sieht jetzt eigentlich ganz
klar das wahlverhalten und damit kann
die fdp natürlich erreichen zu zeigen
die 21 enthaltung können ja nur von der
cdu kommen 22 stimmen für bahnhöfe so
dass man im zweifel sagen könnte hier
die cdu hätte dann doch
für bodo ramelow gewählt also ja man
muss aber gleichzeitig sagen das ist die
fdp stellt nach wie vor den
geschäftsführenden ministerpräsidenten
und der ist bei einer wahl neben einem
der wichtigsten termine ja auch die
einen landtag hat sitzen geblieben mit
seiner fraktion so ich kann auf facebook
kann ich das machen auf youtube und auf
teleskop leider nicht ich werde jetzt
auf facebook
also alle facebook zuschauer einen
kommentar schreiben mit der frage wie
findet ihr das verhalten der fdp gar
nicht abzustimmen und ihr könnt ja die
kommentare voten
das heißt wenn ihr das gut findet könnt
ihr einen daumen hoch bei diesen
kommentar machen und wenn ihr das nicht
gut findet könnt ihr das wütende smiley
auswählen da bin ich mal gespannt was
ihr da so zusagt ihr könnt auch gerne
kommentare dazu beschreiben weil das ist
ja auch hier im stream für euch wohl mit
euch miteinander besprechen wollen was
dort in thüringen gerade passiert so wir
haben es gerade gehört mir noch nie
alles hängt jetzt an der afg kannst du
noch mal kurz die option ein bisschen
zeit hast du glaub ich noch aufzählen
was jetzt passieren kann
also ja also grundsätzlich wenn man
davon ausgeht dass alles irgendwie gut
und problemlos ausgeht dann wäre es so
dass bodo ramelow die mehrheit die
einfache mehrheit erzielen würde weil
hinter ihnen stehen ja spd linke und
grüne und die haben zusammen die meisten
stimmen wir gehen immer von sozusagen 90
aus und die haben 42 stimmen wären hätte
hätte 22 stimmen also das wäre jetzt das
glas das szenario dass bodo ramelow dann
im dritten wahlgang mit der einfachen
mehrheit gewählt wird ich glaube die fdp
wird weiterhin sitzen bleiben
die cdu wird sich enthalten und die
frage ist jetzt wirklich nur im dritten
wahlgang wie die afg reagieren wird sie
wollten jetzt die pause
werden sie ihren kandidaten zurückziehen
werden sie sich dann enthalten oder
werden sie für bodo ramelow stoff wenn
sie für bodo ramelow stimmen dann ist
relativ klar dann fängt das prozedere
von vorne an oder hat dann die linke
schon gesagt wenn die das machen dann
lösen wir den
an landtag auf nein so klar gesagt hat
sie es nicht was man was aber der
unterschied zu kemmerich war der vor
vier wochen gewählt wurde er war damals
er hatte selbst nur fünf stunden seine
fraktion auf die stimmen der afg
angewiesen
das wäre bodo ramelow in dem fall nicht
er hätte er könnte sagen na ja ich habe
ja die mehrheit aus meinem lager
bekommen von rot-rot-grün und war ja nie
auf die stimmen der afg angewiesen
ob aber ein ministerpräsident dann mit
diesem makel weiter regieren wird dass
die afg ihn mit gestimmt hat das ist die
große frage wie bodo ramelow dann damit
umgehen würde wäre es nicht so dann
würden weitere schritte folgen und dann
müsste die fraktion hier eine änderung
der tagesordnung beantragen und dann
ging das ganze bürokratische prozedere
los die tagesordnung zu ändern und dann
änderungsantrag zu stellen und so weiter
um dann eventuell eine
parlamentsauflösung anzustreben dafür
braucht es aber auch wieder eine tage
frist und das hieße am ende wieder
thüringen ist ohne richtig amtierenden
ministerpräsidenten ohne minister und
die hängepartie ginge dann weiter eine
frage wenn dann die die hier auch im
livestream öfter aufgetaucht ist ist was
es draußen vor dem thüringer landtag los
ich kann es noch mal kurz zeigen eine
userin hat uns geschickt
screenshots aus quasi aus dem stream
hier kann man es kurz einmal kurz auf
meinem bildschirm hier sind hinter der
landtagspräsidentin der sind der große
fenster sind fahnen zu sehen
hast du eine ahnung wer draußen
protestiert wie viele es irgend wo die
herkommen
also hier drin im landtag hören wir seit
dem ersten wahlgang von anfang an
wirklich ganz viele trillerpfeifen
buhrufe pfiffe und eben diese fahnen der
antifa das war das was ich sehen konnte
ein plakat omas gegen rechts also hier
sind offenbar viele menschen auf der
straße die natürlich auch sauer sind
über das handeln was wir eben in den
letzten monaten
die politik geliefert hat hier in
thüringen
und ich denke die proteste werden jetzt
auch weiterhin anhalten vielleicht
schaffen wir es ja noch ein bild von
dazu kriegen das würde mich erst mal
interessieren dieses außen tatsächlich
aus gibt es den menschen da sind melanie
ich sage jetzt erst mal vielen dank wir
haben jetzt noch ein paar minuten zeit
du musst dich auch mal schauen was da
gerade passiert den kulissen und dann
gucken wir nach dem dritten wahlgang
nochmals zu dir danke erst mal so ich
würde vorschlagen dass ich das ganze
zieht stellt euch ein timer 15 uhr 55
klosters sind jetzt 20 minuten
ich glaube jetzt noch mal alles zu
besprechen macht gerade nicht so richtig
viel sind ich kann noch mal ganz kurz
für alle die jetzt zu schalten und sich
dafür interessieren zusammenfassen
wir suchen natürlich sucht den
ministerpräsidenten und findet ihnen
gerade nicht der erste wahlgang und der
zweite wahlgang hatte kein ergebnis bodo
ramelow ist es nicht geworden wie ein
hobby ist das auch nicht geworden
das heißt im dritten wahlgang geht
einfach nur darum wer kriegt die meisten
stimmen
am wichtigsten ist da die afg die die
sich jetzt verhalten wird werden wir
gleich sehen
die hat nämlich diese zweite pause
zwischen dem zweiten und den dritten
wahlgang beantragt die beraten sich
gerade wie ein hacker hat von
vorhergesagt behält sich vor nicht
nochmal anzutreten oder vielleicht doch
nochmal anzutreten das ist quasi
wirklich die große spannung gerade und
deswegen würde ich sagen das lohnt sich
den live stream an zu lassen wir
schalten denn ungefähr zehn minuten noch
mal ins studio ist nur eine kurze pause
zeigen euch diese wunderschönen ein
schleife bilder aus dem thüringer
landtag da ist eine
sitzungsunterbrechung also nach durch
einen timer an am handy dann könnt ihr
in zehn minuten wieder dabei sein weil
dann sprechen wir hier weiter mit
unserem partei vor parteienforscher
karl-rudolf korte über das was da gerade
passiert im thüringer landtag das ist
wirklich muss man sagen auch für leute
die sich nicht für politik großartig
interessieren echt spannend bis gleich
[Musik]
ich wollte mal oben anrufen ob die den
dritt
[Musik]
so darf sind weder die sitze in den
theorien rand land im thüringer landtag
ist immer noch unterbrochen müsste aber
gleich weitergehen eigentlich jetzt 1555
war von der landtagspräsidentin an
beraubt das nun wieder zusammenkommt bis
jetzt ist aber alles noch relativ leer
aber birgit keller sitzt hier schon und
wartet auf die abgeordneten der dritte
wahlgang geht es gleich los und der ist
jetzt wirklich entscheidend denn da
reicht die einfache mehrheit deswegen
alle menschen die jetzt gerade zu gucken
teilt den stream mit euren freunden
verwandten die sich vielleicht dafür
interessieren könnten
weil jetzt geht es noch mal richtig los
das wird wirklich spannend aber was kann
mein persönliches um kommentare betteln
wie youtuber das hätten wir nicht nötig
pascal windows schaffst dass wir hinter
unsere zuschauerzahlen noch einmal 30
packen dann hören wir auf damit
also es geht gleich weiter wir warten
darauf dass eben thüringer landtag quasi
der dritte wahlgang anberaumt wird die
ersten beiden wahlgänge sind identisch
abgelaufenen ich kann es noch mal kurz
zusammenfassen 90 sitze hat der landtag
fünf stimmen wurden nicht abgegeben
das waren sehr wahrscheinlich die
stimmen der fdp die sind nämlich auch
sitzen im leben als sie aufgerufen
wurden so und da höre ich jetzt es geht
so weiter birgit keller die
landtagspräsidentin ruft die
abgeordneten in den sitzungssaal und
begrüßt sie aber wir sehen das nicht so
viel los
70 absatz 3 satz 3 der verfassung des
freistaats thüringen und § 47 satz 3 der
geschäftsordnung ist gewählt wer in
einem weiteren wahlgang die meisten
stimmen erhält wenn im ersten und im
zweiten wahlgang niemand die stimmen der
mehrheit der mitglieder des landtages
erhalten hat das war der ausgang des
zweiten wahlganges deshalb frage ich ob
die vorschläge aufrechterhalten werden
wie wir sie im ersten und zweiten
wahlgang hatten damit frage ich gibt es
weitere vorschläge
das kann ich nicht erkennen damit ist
vorgeschlagen für diesen dritten
wahlgang erneut herrn abgeordneten bodo
ramelow als kandidat aufzunehmen eine
weitere kandidatin bzw ein weiterer
kandidat wurde nicht vorgeschlagen
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich möchte
ihnen dazu den stimmzettel für diesen
dritten wahlgang mit nur einem
kandidaten erläutern
aus respekt vor dem hohen haus dem
verfassungsgerichtshof und dem zu wählen
den ministerpräsidenten im bewusstsein
um die bedeutung der von mir zu
treffenden entscheidung sowie unter
beachtung der mir aufgegebene neutralen
und unparteiischen amtsführung hatte ich
es angesichts der fortbestehenden
widerstreitenden meinungen darüber mit
wie vielen stimmen der ministerpräsident
im dritten wahlgang bei nur einen
kandidaten gewählt ist für geboten dem
stimmt den stimmzettel so zu gestalten
dass auch im dritten wahlgang bei nur
einem kandidaten jede bzw ihre
abgeordnete entweder mit ja oder nein
oder enthaltung stimmen kann
ich bitte nun die wahlhelferinnen und
wahlhelfer herren abgeordneten schütze
herrn abgeordneten gottweis und frau
abgeordnete dr klisch erneut nach vorn
ich eröffne die wahlhandlung und bitte
die schriftführerin beziehungsweise
schriftführer die namen der abgeordneten
zu verlesen bitteschön adam scott aus
rené baum franziska beyer patrick bugner
durch dr bergnot
sascha
blechschmidt andré prager turm
andreas kotter jens
von torsten ites steffen
cordula so und für alle denen das gerade
nicht so richtig klar war was da
passiert ist im thüringer landtag mal
ganz kurz die wichtige info viren hacker
hat seine kandidatur zurückgezogen im
dritten wahlgang steht damit nur noch
bodo ramelow zur wahl
das heißt damit ist es relativ sicher
dass er gewählt wird
die landtagspräsidentin blicke keller
hat gerade auch noch mal das prozedere
erläutert wie viele stimmen braucht man
bis man gewählt wird wenn du musst nur
noch einen kandidaten gibt es heißt auf
den stimmzetteln steht jetzt nicht mehr
ein oder zwei stehen nicht mehr zwei
sondern nur noch ja nein und enthaltung
und sie hat nicht richtig erklärt ob
eine jahr stimmen erreichen würde aber
wir können davon ausgehen dass das nicht
der fall sein wird wahrscheinlich
jedenfalls die afg hat den kandidaten
blöcke zurückgezogen und damit quasi den
weg frei gemacht für bodo ramelow ist
sei denn jetzt müssen wir schauen wie
gerade leicht abgestimmt wird weil die
spannende sache ist jetzt die vier
stimmen entfallen auch bodo ramelow und
er braucht ja noch vier stimmen
von daher ist jetzt die frage es könnte
natürlich auch auf die stimme sein
unser parteienforscher klaus rudolf
korte nochmal zur einordnung das ist
noch mal eine kamera abgelenkt aber sie
hören mich super dass politiker sie
können sie das mal kurz erläutern also
hier und heute tritt nicht mehr zur wahl
an
bodo ramelow ist der einzige kandidat
jetzt könnt ihr aber nicht mehr sagen
für wen quasi wenn er mit mehr als 42
stimmen gewählt werden würde wo diese
vier stimmen herkommen richtig ja es
kann ja auch sein dass die ard sich
enthält kann auch sein dass sie ihn
spektakulär einfach mit wählt das wissen
bin ich könnte auf jeden fall wissen wir
dass bei einer normalen mathematischen
formel die mehrheit von rot rot grün die
ihren ramelow wählen
auf jeden fall eine einfache mehrheit in
diesem landtag haben wird beim dritten
wahlgangs insofern kann er auch durchaus
stimmen von der fdp spiels weise mit in
kauf nehmen ohne am ende sagen zu müssen
das wären stimmen die ihn dazu führen am
ende die wahl nicht anzunehmen
okay das heißt dass halten sie für
ausgeschlossen dass badu bodo ramelow
nach der wahl wenn er zum beispiel mit
50 stimmen gewählt wird wo man sich dann
fragt wo kommen die acht stimmen her
dann sagt das kann ich nicht annehmen
weil ich muss davon ausgehen dass
darunter auch alle stimmen sind genau
das wäre anders gewesen erst im zweiten
wahlgang werden dort sichtbar gewesen
wäre beispielsweise 22 zusätzliche
stimmen von der afd
dann hätte er mit sicherheit die wahl
nicht angenommen hier ist es aber so
dass bei einfacher mehrheit eher er
normalerweise eine mehrheit hat und
insofern können ein paar stimmen mehr
ihnen sicherlich nicht dazu bringen die
war nicht anzunehmen
aber die afg spekuliert genau darauf und
sie spekuliert auf eine juristische
prüfung der normalerweise einfache
mehrheit setzt ja voraus dass auch in
anderen kandidaten oder kandidatin gibt
die ist nicht da es wird ja vor dem
verfassungsgericht mit sicherheit dann
noch mal in thüringen geprüft insofern
sehen wir wieder die afg spielt mit
verfassung spielt mit institutionen und
möchte genau das provozieren das heißt
das was auf den ersten blick jetzt für
den laien vielleicht so aussieht wie ach
wie nett die afg macht den weg frei für
bodo ramelow und steht wie eine hecke
nicht mehr auf hat sich quasi ja der mit
der einfachen mehrheit von rot rot grün
im landtag gebeugt das ist nicht so
einfach
nein es ist eigentlich ein raffinierter
schachzug um die regierenden parteien
die vermeintlich regierenden in eine
defensive zu bringen das ergebnis zu
verunklaren und insofern die perspektive
eine zusammenarbeit oder eine
perspektive für die legislaturperiode zu
erschweren
die perspektive grundsätzlich hat sich
im moment zwischen cdu und rot-rot-grün
verbessert denn offenbar verlässlich
haben sie diszipliniert im ersten und
zweiten wahlgang abgestimmt und damit
dass die perspektive
im nächsten monaten vielleicht punktuell
bei gemeinsamkeiten für den haushalt zum
beispiel zusammenzuarbeiten und auch ein
mehrheit herbeizuführen so fern ist der
tag heute sehr wichtig für die kommenden
monate
und das was die beiden fraktionen oder
die drei regierenden fraktionen und die
eine cdu fraktion heute an den tag
gelegt habe spricht dafür dass die
minderheitsregierung durchaus
funktionieren kann
können sie schon abschätzen wie diese
tricksereien der afg wie sie das ja
gerade auch quasi genannt haben
bei den wählern ankommen das war ja
schon im ersten wahl versucht oder bei
der ersten wahl vor vier wochen sodass
der afg da vorgeworfen wurde sie würde
tricksen hat dass irgendwelche oder
welche auswirkung hat das gehabt in den
umfragen und image da es die die
wählerinnen und wähler der fdp fühlen
sich bestätigt eine partei zu wählen die
im protest versucht auch das politische
system mit zu schreddern
das ist angesagt und auch wenn sie
zweitstärkste partei in thüringen war er
nicht gewählt worden ist um ein
politisches system zu stabilisieren
sondern er ist in frage zu stellen so
sind ein großteil der wählerinnen und
wähler hinter der ard
unabhängig von inhaltlichen positionen
vielleicht auch ideologischen das ist
nicht das kann man von den begriff
altparteien und gegen das system
vorzugehen durchaus erkennen und das
liegt genau auf dieser linie ich kann
mir vorstellen dass wählerinnen und
wähler die gerade auch jetzt wieder
meinen zu erkennen das ja der bei der
letzten wahl einiges aus bundesrichter
offenbar abgelehnt worden ist und
deshalb thüringen sich fügen muss sich
darin bestätigt fühlen
diese dieses system was sie offenbar ich
wirklich gut finden durch die afg auch
zu stabilisieren und hier ist etwas
besonderes wie wir es international auch
beobachten können das wird ja auch
vorgemacht international politics
systeme zu schreddern
auch das ist ein teil davon
sofern die kreide als einschalten wir
befinden uns im dritten wahlgang zum
ministerpräsidenten wahl in thüringen
die afg hat ihren kandidaten wie und
hecke zurückgezogen das heißt bodo
ramelow von der linken ist gerade der
einzige kandidat wird daher mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit gewählt aber die
frage ist dann was als nächstes passiert
denn parteienforscher rudolf korte hat
gerade schon gesagt das ist quasi ein
parlamentarischer trick wieder der afg
um eventuell auch vors
verfassungsgericht zu ziehen
jetzt konnte gerade pascal ist auf
periscope sehr aktiv und hat eine
schlaue idee der meinte es wäre doch
schlau wenn sich jetzt 22 leute von der
linken enthalten weil dann könnte man so
quasi verschleiern awp die afg mit
gestimmt hat oder nicht und für bodo
ramelow würde es ja schon reichen wenn
du 20 leute für ihn stimmen ja es gibt
sogar die herrschende meinung innerhalb
der rechtsprechung das mit einer ja
stimme er auch gewählt würde wenn du ein
kandidat an
das klingt kurios sofern wird das vor
dem verfassungsgericht in karlsruhe aber
in thüringen auf jeden fall landen aber
es reicht eine ja stimme aus um bei
einem kandidaten im dritten wahlgang ein
zum ministerpräsidenten zu machen
das ganze erinnert mich tatsächlich dass
gerade so ein bisschen an so ein
taktisches american football spiel wo
die gegner sich zurückziehen kurz sich
eine taktik überlegen und dann
aufeinander zu rennen
meinen sie dass die linke und spd und
grüne mit diesem ruf gerechnet haben der
afg und sich das in dementsprechend
darauf einstellen können
also wer nach der letzten wahl nicht mit
allem rechnet der wäre sehr naiv und hat
ja wochenlang mit der zeit gehabt um so
auf die verschiedenen szenarien sich
einzustellen
erstmals in der parlamentarischen
geschichte ist ein kandidat beim letzten
mal denn nominiert worden ist von der
eigenen fraktion mit null stimmen
bedacht worden ist er somit
parlamentarischen verfahren umgeht ist
zu allem in der lage und insofern wäre
es extrem fahrlässig nicht davon
auszugehen dass die afg sich für eins
zwei oder drei wahlgänge kuriositäten
überlegt und das spricht jetzt auch für
den dritten wahlgang bei dem wir auch
eine kuriosität erleben werden
herr korte vielen dank bis hierhin wir
schalten jetzt wieder zurück in den
thüringer landtag und sind gespannt wie
weit wird dort sind in den abstimmungen
die abgeordneten werden weiter
aufgerufen das prozedere wer die ersten
beiden wahlgänge verpasst hat er gleich
noch mal ganz kurz
es gibt eine alphabetische reihenfolge
in den nachnamen dh sie werden
alphabetisch aufgerufen bei auf einmal
an
dann kommen sie einzeln durchs parlament
kriegen hier einen stimmzettel laufen
damit in eine der beiden wahlkabinen
machen dort ein kreuzchen und werfen das
ganze dann hier in die urne und an
diesen tisch wird auch gleich ausgezählt
und wir hören jetzt mal wie weit man in
thüringen mit dem bvb schon ist das
heißt wenn wir damit rechnen können dass
es in die auszählung geht
zwar jetzt
sehr geehrte damen und herren konnten
alle abgeordneten ihre stimme abgeben
ich sehe keinen widerspruch damit stelle
ich fest dass alle abgeordneten ihre
stimme abgeben konnten und ich bitte die
aus um die auszählung auszählung der
stimmen und schließe die wahlhandlung
bitteschön
so die auszählung läuft also gerade hier
werden wieder hoffen gebildet für ja
nein oder enthaltung und es gibt hier
immer wieder die frage was passiert wenn
es mehr nein stimmen gilt als ja stimmen
da hat uns parteienforscher karl-rudolf
korte gerade erklärt dem gespräch es
reicht im grunde nach der jetzigen
rechtsauffassung eine einzige jahr
stimme für bodo ramelow damit er als
ministerpräsident des landes thüringen
gewählt ist dh es können auch 89 nein
stimmen seien damit ist jetzt nicht zu
rechnen weil allein die angepeilte rot
rot grüne koalition hat ja 42 stimmen
und die cdu hat sich bis jetzt enthalten
das heißt wir können davon ausgehen dass
sie sich auch weiter enthalten wird
frage ist das wie die afg sich verhalten
wird denn da ist die tatsächlich die
große frage darauf spekuliert die
fraktionen wahrscheinlich wenn sie jetzt
gesammelt für jahr stimmen das können
wir auch gleich rein rechnerisch
versuchen auseinander zu klammern
dann muss herr ramelow davon ausgehen
dass an der afg stimmen gewählt wurde
das wäre etwas gesagt hat das will ja
eigentlich nicht aber herr korte war
gerade im gespräch der meinung dass er
das dann trotzdem machen könnte wir
werden sehen wie sich herr ramelow
gleich verhält und wie die stimmabgabe
aussieht das wird also tatsächlich
spannend hier die nächsten minuten weil
immer noch alles komplett offen ist wir
wissen nicht wie es weitergeht auch wenn
es auf den ersten blick so aussieht na
klar herr ramelow wird gewählt und dann
ist der drops gelutscht und thüringen
hat wieder einen ministerpräsidenten der
tatsächlich regieren kann und will
aber ganz so einfach ist es dann wohl
doch nicht wir schauen weiter zu da
werden stapel gebildet es wird das sehen
wir gerade gerechnet zusammengezählt
das heißt wir können davon ausgehen dass
die damen und herren mit dem ergebnis
gleich richtung sitzungsleitung gehen
zur landtagspräsidentin birgit keller
von der linken die dann das ergebnis
vorlesen wird
ich hatte ja so eben mal gefragt im
livestream wie ihr das findet auf
facebook dass die kfd gar nicht
abgestimmt hat bis jetzt ich kann es ja
gerade nicht sehen
christian konntest du das sehen ich habe
ja gefragt wie die zuschauer das finden
dass die fdp gar nicht
stimmt hat hast du da wieviel likes und
wie viele böse gesichter haben wir
gekriegt du findest es ich finden kann
es nicht richtig erkennen gerade hier
okay an diesem abstimmungs tool arbeiten
war nochmal das müssen meine ideen ein
gefühl zu kriegen wie er das findet so
und da geht es jetzt richtung
sitzungsleitung und wir warten auf das
ergebnis
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich gebe
sich das ergebnis des dritten wahlgangs
bekannt abgegebene stimmzettel 85
ungültige keine gültige stimmzettel 85
auf den wahlvorschlag der fraktion die
linke der spd und bündnis 90/die grünen
drucksache 7 strich 340 abgeordnete bodo
ramelow in vielen ja stimmen 42 nein
stimmen 23 enthaltung 20 damit sind die
meisten stimmen erreicht
damit hat herr abgeordneter bodo ramelow
die meisten stimmen im sinne des
artikels 70 absatz 3 satz 3 der
verfassung des freistaates thüringen und
§ 47 satz 3 der geschäftsordnung
erhalten ich frage sie herr abgeordneter
ramelow nehmen sie die wahl an
dann darf ich ihnen gratulieren
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte damen und herren damit darf
ich den ersten tagesordnungspunkt
abschließen und ich rufe auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 2 die vereidigung des
ministerpräsidenten des freistaates
thüringen ich bitte den
ministerpräsidenten zu seiner
vereidigung nach vorn die anwesenden
bitte ich sich von ihren plätzen zu
erheben
sehr geehrter herr ministerpräsident
ramelow ich verlesen die in artikel 71
der verfassung des freistaates thüringen
vorgeschriebene eidesformel und bitte
sie diese eines vorbild nachzusprechen
sie können den eid anschließend mit den
worten so wahr mir gott helfe
bekräftigen die eidesformel lautete ich
schwöre ich schwöre dass ich meine kraft
dem wohle des volkes widmen dass ich
meine kraft dem wohle des volkes widmen
verfassung und gesetze barren verfassung
und gesetze waren meine pflichten
gewissenhaft erfüllen meine pflichten
gewissenhaft erfüllen und gerechtigkeit
gegen jedermann üben werde und
gerechtigkeit gegen jedermann üben werde
ich schwöre
maximal mikrofon kurz auf so damit ist
bodo ramelow als ministerpräsident des
freistaates thüringen
man muss sagen wiedergewählt
zwischendurch gab es jetzt kurz thomas
kenner richter steht gerade bei ihm
überreicht ihm einen blumenstrauß wenn
ich das richtig sehe
und er ist vereidigt gewählt und
offensichtlich wenn wir uns das
stimmergebnis angucken 42 jahre stimmen
für bodo ramelow hat die afd nicht für
bodo ramelow gestimmt sondern es war
geschlossen die rot-rot-grüne angepeilte
koalition 23 nein-stimmen gab es 20
enthaltungen
das sieht danach aus dass ist die cdu
fraktion gewesen ist 85 stimmen wurden
abgegeben fünf fehlen also das wird
wieder die fdp fraktion gewesen sein
das heißt es gab jetzt hier
wahrscheinlich eine relativ
diszipliniertes verhalten zumindest von
cdu und fdp
und wir warten jetzt darauf ob bodo
ramelow noch eine rede halten wird und
ein paar worte verlesen zu seiner wahl
er nimmt gerade die glückwünsche
entgegen
da fallen ernste worte kannst das
gesicht sieht man bei ihm
ich sag mal ein wirklich erfreut der
ministerpräsident sieht doch ein
bisschen anders aus aber im endeffekt
ist er jetzt erst mal gewählt wie das
jetzt weitergeht in thüringen wird auch
spannend denn im fehlen für die
parlamentarische arbeit für das regieren
weiterhin vier stimmen das heißt er muss
schauen wo er sich mehrheiten besorgen
kann damit er überhaupt regieren kann
dann gibt es ja zumindest einen deal ein
abkommen ein protokoll mit der cdu
thüringen diese gesagt haben
wir würden mitmachen und ich höre gerade
unsere gesprächspartner karl rudolf
korte hat sich das alles angehört
zugeschaut und bin jetzt gespannt wie
sie das einordnen die afg hat also nicht
für bodo ramelow gestimmt davon können
wir jetzt wahrscheinlich ausgehen
das heißt hat die elf die sich dann doch
gebeugt
sich am ende dem verfahren gebeugt hat
und ihren eigenen kandidaten ja nicht
mehr ins rennen gebracht hat sondern
ganz normal wie es hierzu steht mit nein
gestimmt hat juristisch verfassungs
juristisch wird das auch nicht
problematisch werden weil ja eindeutig
mehr ja als nein stimmen da sind der
verfassungsgerichtshof in thüringen
würde ja nur eingreifen wenn er
angerufen würde wenn mehr nein als ja
stimmen gewesen wären das ist aber nicht
der fall so fern ist am ende doch noch
alles gut geworden so weit man sagen
kann dass viel gutes im falschen sich
eigentlich überhaupt nur entwickeln kann
also ich höre bodo ramelow hat jetzt an
der rede als wiedergewählte
ministerpräsident des freistaates
thüringen wir schalten rüber besteht im
chinesischen aus zwei schriftzeichen
diese beiden schriftzeichen kann man
wenn man sie einzeln liest als gefahr
oder als chance lesen
wir haben vor vier wochen hier im
plenarsaal den beginn einer krise erlebt
die zu einer situation geführt hat dass
der freistaat thüringen in ganz
deutschland ja in der ganzen welt
bekannt geworden ist
ich glaube im sinne aller zu sprechen
dass wir auf diese form der bekanntheit
gerne verzichtet hätten
der freistaat thüringen ist ein starker
freistaat die menschen in diesem
freistaat haben in den letzten 30 jahren
mit der freiheit die sie sich erkämpft
haben die weichen gestellt für ein
prosperierendes land und in einem land
in dem wir mittlerweile zu einer
wirtschaftlichen stärke gefunden haben
bei dem auch die themen arbeit
entlohnung und wirtschaftliche
entwicklung nicht mehr widerspruch
stehen im freistaat auf das sich die
menschen verlassen können indem es sich
lohnt zu leben und an freistaat der vor
großen aufgaben steht bei dem
weltoffenheit und toleranz ein zentrales
thema sein muss damit wir menschen
einladen mit uns zu leben bei uns zu
leben und die die in diesem freistaat
leben in ihrer unterschiedlichkeit sich
aushalten und auch lernen miteinander
eine bessere perspektive jeweils sicht
zu erarbeiten
ich darf daran erinnern dass wir bei der
landtagswahl ein wahlergebnis bekommen
haben dass keine leichten antworten
ermöglicht und wir haben in den letzten
vier wochen erlebt dass sich viele in
die thüringer belange eingemischt haben
die wähler in thüringen leben und manche
haben sich eingemischt die von thüringen
überhaupt keine ahnung haben
ich glaube es wäre gut wenn man in der
bundesrepublik deutschland im
dreißigsten jahr der deutschen einheit
versteht dass die bonner republik nicht
mehr existiert sondern die chance der
deutschen einheit die die bürgerinnen
und bürger der ddr sicher kämpft haben
und ja auch die chance sich mit einem
system auseinanderzusetzen das totalitär
den menschen die freiheiten genommen hat
zu atmen oder den eigenen weg zu gehen
oder das eigene leben zu leben oder die
eigene religion zu akzeptieren ja dieses
system ist von den menschen überwunden
worden aber in der heutigen zeit haben
wir menschen die mit unterschiedlichen
religionen bei uns leben und auch die
haben ein recht darauf bei uns zu leben
und sie haben das grundgesetzlich und
verfassungsrechtlich geschützte recht
auf unterschiedliches leben und
unterschiedliche religionen auch
geschützt zu bekommen das ist nicht nur
ein akzeptieren sondern auch an
verteidigen und dieses herangehen
freiheit zu erobern freiheit zu nehmen
und freiheit zu gestalten ist die
aufgabe diesen hohen hauses und ja meine
damen und herren ich habe ein hecke eben
nicht die hand gegeben
das kann man als ungehobelte manieren
betrachten aber dass herr müller sie
sollten dazu ganz schweigen wer vor
jeder kamera
wer vor jeder kamera vor vier wochen in
die kamera kurz nach der wahl von 1
kemmerich der sich zur wahl gestellt hat
und als parlamentarier bereit war
verantwortung für die stimmen aus seiner
fraktion zu übernehmen wer dann in jede
kamera sagt man habe ein kemmerich eine
falle gestellt
man habe herr kemmerich auf eine leihe
route geschickt wer so über die wahl
eines verfassungsorgans spricht der hat
etwas zu klären
und wenn er kämpfen wenn er das in
seiner fraktion klärt und wenn ich
deutlich von nehmen kann dass sich
demokratie im vordergrund steht dann bin
ich bereit auch in merkel die hand zu
geben aber erst dann wenn sie die
demokratie verteidigen und nicht die
demokratie mit füßen treten und niemand
mehr hier im hohen haus weiß wie sie
eigentlich abstimmen warum sie überhaupt
abstimmen oder ob sie wieder fallen
bauen demokraten anderer fraktionen und
eine letzte bemerkung
ich finde es beklemmt was familie
kemmerich passiert ist ich finde es
diese herrschaften hier drüben möchten
gar nicht wissen dies meiner frau
gegangen ist deswegen danke ich meiner
frau dass sie das in den letzten vier
wochen ausgehalten hat was ihr aushalten
mussten und was familie kemmerich
ausgehalten hat wir haben genauso unter
polizeischutz gestanden wie die familie
kemmerich unter polizeischutz gestanden
hat und das bei meinen söhnen auf der
facebook seite steht wir wissen wo ihr
wohnen wir wissen wie ihr heiß und sie
wollen nichts damit zu tun haben sie
sind die brandstifter in diesem saal
deswegen danke ich ausdrücklich allen
die heute dafür gesorgt haben dass wir
heute den ersten tag wieder haben
instabile verhältnisse zu kommen und ich
danke der cdu fraktion
ich danke der cdu fraktion in einer
schwierigen situation
über alle eigenen auseinandersetzung in
der bundes partei hinweg zu sagen wir
müssen gemeinsam für die stabilität
dieses landes sorgen und dann werden wir
auf dieser basis der
stabilitätsmechanismus der heute morgen
um 9 unterschrieben wurde
die neuwahlen vorbereiten weil nur wenn
wir geordnete neuwahlen kommen können
wir den bürgern auch wirklich
ermöglichen dass sie ein wahlergebnis
uns übermitteln damit deutlich wird wer
die verantwortung in diesem hohen haus
in zukunft tragen soll
deswegen werden wir jetzt darauf
hinarbeiten und wir haben die nächsten
monate gemeinsam uns vorgenommen das
betone ich dass eine destruktive
mehrheit hier im haus nicht mehr
entsteht dass wir uns nicht mehr treiben
lassen von einer fraktion die fallen
baut und leim guten in diesem sinne ist
der begriff krise auch der begriff für
eine chance ich denke wir können die
letzten vier wochen nutzen die
bekanntheit von thüringen jetzt
einsetzen und sagen gucken sie unsere
produkte an
nicht nur dass wir es geschafft haben
eine demokratische legitimation krise zu
überwinden und miteinander wieder
geordnete verhältnisse zu kriegen
sondern wir können uns auf die produkte
konzentrieren wir können uns auf die
wahren konzentrieren wir können uns auf
die dienstleistungen konzentrieren und
wir können uns auf die hochschulen
konzentrieren die menschen einladen bei
uns zu studieren oder forscher aus der
ganzen welt mit unterschiedlicher
hautfarbe mit unterschiedlicher
haarfarbe mit unterschiedlicher herkunft
und möglicherweise auch mit
unterschiedlicher religion
diese vielfalt ist der kerngehalt der
des grundgesetzes der bundesrepublik
deutschland und der thüringer verfassung
in diesem sinne sage ich wir sollten
nach vorne gucken weil wir ein fahrzeug
lenkt und immer nur in den rückspiegel
guckt wird am ende wieder nur ein unfall
bauen wir wollen kann unfall bauen wir
wollen den menschen sagen es geht nach
vorne und dafür bin ich bereit meine
kraft für dieses land einzusetzen und
ich baue auf die unterstützung der
demokratischen fraktionen in diesem
hohen haus vielen dank
[Applaus]
ja so weit die ersten worte von bodo
ramelow als neu gewählter
ministerpräsident des freistaates
thüringen der hat ganz klar aufgeteilt
in richtung fdp fraktion hat ich habe es
mit geschrieben im motorraum gesagt sie
sind die brandstifter in diesem saal und
er hat sich geweigert wir eine hecke die
hand zu geben
die sprechen noch einmal mit unserem
parteienforscher karl-rudolf korte über
die rede und über das ergebnis
halten sie die worte für gerechtfertigt
oder ist es nicht vielleicht auch mal
zeit das kriegsbeil zu begraben und zu
sagen ich bin gewählt worden
die afg hat sich zurückgezogen und jetzt
können wir wieder in parlamentarische
verhältnisse zurückkehren
er hat es noch einmal gesteigert auch in
einem stil nicht die hand sich geben zu
lassen von der decke die abgrenzung ist
also sehr markant und er hat es ja auch
begründet einmal durch die verfahren die
die elf die nicht nur missachtet hat im
parlamentarischen system sondern sie wie
ein spieler missachtet hat und darauf
gesetzt hat den parlamentarischen staat
geradezu lächerlich zu machen und er hat
es zum zweiten inhaltlich begründet dass
eine demokratie eben aufgerufen ist mit
vielfalt pluralistisch umzugehen und
nicht einzelne und andere auszugrenzen
und insofern wirft er der afc in dem
zurückliegenden wahlkampf nach wie vor
vor
diese ausgrenzung zum maßstab ihrer
politik zu machen und das passt nicht
meint herr ramelow zur verfassung von
thüringen und auch nicht zum grundgesetz
die davon ausgeht die würde des menschen
zu schützen und nicht zu unterscheiden
welcher mensch damit gemeint ist jetzt
mal abschließend kurzen ausblick wie es
jetzt weitergeht herr ramelow ist
ministerpräsident der hat angekündigt
heute nachmittag noch sein papa also
sein
seine regierung zusammenzustellen die
minister zu ernennen die staatssekretäre
zu ernennen und alle zu verteidigen wenn
ich ihn richtig verstanden habe hat er
jetzt auch vor mit hilfe der cdu eine
minderheitsregierung zu führen und dann
doch neu zu fehlen bald oder
ja ich sehe das als unproblematisch an
in nrw wurde zwar unter anderen
rahmenbedingungen über zweieinhalb jahre
mit einer minderheit regiert eines der
größten europäischen länder da wenn das
wird man dass die thüringen auch
hinbekommen zugegebenermaßen sind die
wahl voraussetzungen hier andere gewesen
aber die vereinbarung offenbar mit der
union mit der cdu beziehen sich genau
daraufhin am ende 60 stimmen im landtag
zusammen zu bekommen in den landtag
geordnet aufzulösen
dann wenn jetzt die dringendsten
inhaltlichen probleme gelöst sind und
man kann schon sagen probleme schlagen
ideologien die probleme die zur lösung
die wählerinnen und wähler ja auch
wünschen dass sie gelöst werden das soll
jetzt angegangen werden mit punktuellen
mehrheiten in düsseldorf war es
letztlich so dass ein mehrheiten
zustande kam über zweieinhalb jahren mit
allen verschiedenen fraktionen märz
fähig waren und hier wird mit sicherheit
im landtag von thüringen darauf geachtet
dass keine entscheidung zustande kommen
mit einer mehrheit die ausschließlich
für eine mehrheit mit der fdp bei
geführt wenn da bin ich ziemlich sicher
aber das kann man verhindern wenn man
sich entsprechend abspricht und
koordiniert gut das werden wir
beobachten für heute erstmal vielen dank
herr korte für ihre zeit für ihre
ausführlichen einschätzungen und
antworten euch im livestream vielen dank
fürs dranbleiben für das zugucken das
war ein doch sehr spannender politischer
nachmittag der am ende dann doch das
ergebnis hat was sich rot-rot-grün
gewünscht hat nämlich bodo ramelow ist
wiedergewählt als ministerpräsident des
freistaates thüringen dass dort nicht
alles gute das haben wir gerade in
seiner rede schon gehört er hat quasi
der afg den fehdehandschuh hingeworfen
hat gesagt so wie ihr hier verhalten
habt das geht nicht ihr seid die
brandstifter hier im saal das wird die
afg so nicht auf sich sitzen lassen das
heißt das wird auf jeden fall
weitergehen aber für jetzt machen wir
erstmal den stream zu ich danke euch
fürs zugucken fürs kommentieren und sagt
bis zum nächsten großereignis
[Musik]